(horn blowing)
- How do you put on a
hoodie like a boomer?
I don't how you've managed
to find a way to do it.
It's a fucking hoodie.
(sound effect pops)
- You haven't worn a hoodie before, Chris?
(Garnt laughs)
- Oh my God,
Chris in a hoodie just looks
like that fucking, "Hello, fellow kids."
(all laughing)
(moderate music)
Hello, everyone,
welcome back to another episode
of the Trash Taste podcast.
I'm your host for today, Joey,
and I'm with the boys, as per usual,
and we have a familiar face.
What's that?
What was that?
(Garnt chuckling)
- Do you wanna say that again?
(all laughing)
- This is like the biggest
podcast in the world.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
People moving the set
around while we're filming.
You'd never get this on
the Abroad in Japan studio,
'cause there's nobody in there.
There's nobody in there.
- Do you want to introduce
yourself to our audience, Chris?
- It's your boy, Chris, innit?
- Your boy. (chuckling)
- Your boy.
(Garnt and Connor laughs)
It's your boy.
Am I cool now?
'Cause I say, "Your boy."
Like Joey.
- You sound like
a grime rapper.
- Yeah, how you doing, guys?
Good to see you all.
- Welcome back.
- Good to see you as well.
- For the fourth time.
- Good to see you.
- The fourth time, the
fourth one, the big one.
- The big one?
- The big one.
- How you guys doing?
- Yeah, doing all right.
- Prepare yourself for another episode
of Chris tries not to get canceled.
So.
- Yeah, yeah.
(Chris and Joey laughs)
- [Chris] Got two hours.
- I wonder what we're gonna
have to cut from this episode.
(Connor and Joey laughs)
- Everything to play for.
I'm in a good mood though.
I was recently in Japan Times.
I was described as affable.
- (chuckling) What?
- Right, affable.
- Affable, in what sense?
- Thinking of rebranding
to Affable in Japan.
(Joey chuckles)
But I'm not just affable in name,
I'm affable (chuckling) in nature.
I don't even know what affable,
what does it mean, affable?
- What's the definition of affable?
- It's somebody who's approachable.
- Affable.
- Affable, approachable, relatable.
- Why not just say approachable?
- Approachable in Japan.
- You're like a male Karen.
- Well, I'm affable,
and I've bought Christmas presents.
It's a little bit late.
- Oh, yeah.
- Chris, it's February.
- It's February, Chris.
- What are you doing
bringing Christmas presents?
- Well, you didn't invite me in a while.
- It's definitely not
the 21st of December,
we're filming this in.
- I've been camping out
the front, this studio,
for a whole month,
waiting to be allowed in.
(Joey laughs)
Not my fault.
Anyway, here we go.
- My God.
Did you wrap those presents yourself?
- Oh, you wrapped them up.
- Oh, my God,
you actually wrapped them up.
- I am affable.
(all laughing)
- What an affable move.
- Who's got what?
What's this one?
- You're the one that wrapped it up.
- I've forgotten which one's which.
- You'd be the worst fucking Santa ever.
(Joey and Garnt chuckles)
You're just at the kids' house,
like, "Fuck, uh."
- [Joey] "Well, one of them is yours."
- Oh, there's Garnt, that's you.
- Oh, thank you very much.
- Let me guess.
- Animation, that's you.
- That's me.
- Animation.
- Animation, it says
animation. (chuckling)
- I have a feeling like I might
know what yours is, Garnt.
- Concede, okay.
There you go.
- Oh, my, oh my, oh my God, Chris.
- And before we open these presents,
where's my present?
- Oh yeah, we actually
have a gift for you.
- We have a gift for you.
- We have a gift, yeah.
- What is it?
Some sort of insulting artwork
of me look like a fucking
bowling ball again?
- This is Trash Taste merch.
- No,
we want you to confirm
your victory for most drip
in the Trash Taste awards this year.
So we got you some
drip, Chris. (chuckling)
- Thank you very much, guys.
Trash Taste merchandise.
- Try it on, Chris.
- Oh thank you so much.
(all laughing)
- [Connor] Try it on, Chris.
- [Garnt] Yeah, you
should try it on, Chris.
- I'll try it on a little
bit later on in the show.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- It's the first present.
- Will it actually fit?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think so.
- It's a large size.
- It's big size.
- [Garnt] It's big size.
- How dare you make some assumptions?
- You'll have some drip now for once.
- Well, open your presents then,
let's get this outta the way.
- Should we do it one at a
time or just go all together?
- Well, let's start
with Joey, yeah.
- Start with Joey.
- Okay.
- All right.
- So I asked the man.
- Why is this so heavy?
- I asked the man at the toy store,
what all the kids want this Christmas.
(Joey and Connor laughs)
And this was what he said, yeah.
- Oh well, you picked all right,
'cause I've always wanted this.
- There you go.
- It's the Mario kart.
- Yeah.
- Go kart.
(hands clapping)
- Affable, yeah.
- [Connor] Okay, that's actually decent.
- [Garnt] That's actually
a pretty decent present.
- That's the one-
- Oh and you got batteries.
- And I got batteries.
- Oh my God.
- That's the first time
where batteries are included,
thank God.
- Affable, innit?
Affable.
- Is this the one that I
played around in your studio?
- No, it's not as expensive as that one.
(Connor and Joey laughs)
That's cheap.
- It's the cheap, shit one.
- But you can drive that
around and drive Aki mental.
- Hell yeah.
- Driving it around the apartment.
Yeah.
- That's such a cool toy.
- Yeah, hell yeah.
Aw thanks, Chris, appreciate that.
- Good friends.
- Let me see,
let me see what I got.
- Garnt.
So this is a shared present
with you and Sydney.
I know you've got your
new place and I figured-
- Ooh, thank you very much.
- I thought that was a bottle of wine.
- [Joey] Yeah, I thought
that was a bottle of wine.
- I honestly thought this
was a bottle of wine.
- [Chris] I think Garnt's got enough wine.
- You brought a yakitori set, thank you.
- [Chris] You can enjoy
that with your wine.
- Thank you very much.
- [Chris] And cook some yakitori.
- This will be perfect in our new kitchen.
- You look like you're really
forcing yourself to say that.
- (laughing) No, no, no.
- This will be a, yeah.
- Genuinely we've been looking
for kitchen appliances,
'cause we are experimenting
with a lot of cooking.
So.
- Oh nice.
(wrapping paper rustles)
And Connor.
Don't worry, it's not-
- Why's it so heavy?
- [Chris] It's not a bomb, don't worry.
(wrapping paper rustles)
- [Joey] Oh look.
(Connor laughs)
Oh it's a poker set.
- It's a poker set.
- Poker set.
- This is for you, Chris.
- [Joey] So you can-
- Connors like, "When
I come to your house,
I can take all your money."
(Joey laughs)
- It's good though.
- Well,
I did beat you at poker recently.
- For legal reasons we need to say
we don't obviously bet money on poker.
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah it's illegal.
- No, definitely not.
- 'Cause gambling is illegal.
- It's fucking heavy.
What are these chips made of?
Rocks?
- [Chris] Maybe next time
you could beat me at poker.
Now you can practice at home.
(Garnt chuckles)
- I'll defeat you next time.
- Wait, he beat you at poker?
- No, I beat him.
- Okay, yeah.
- He needs to practice.
- I beat him as well,
I beat him as well.
- Destroyed him, he's rubbish.
- This is what happened, right,
we were getting it,
the night was going on long,
I'd already collected all the money.
(Chris grunts)
And I'm like, "Fine,
let's just all or nothing,
let's come on, the night's over."
(Garnt chuckles)
And then Chris won,
and then here now he
won't let me forget it.
(Joey chuckles)
- That's not what happened.
We went for two hours,
it was 11 o'clock, PM,
11 PM when we started.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And Connor was winning
for the first hour,
and he's like,
"What time does this place close?
What time does it open?"
It was until one.
He's like, "Well, we'll
stay all night, we'll play."
(Joey chuckles)
- No, it was not.
- And he did really well,
he was doing really well to be fair.
He annihilated this poor Japanese man.
- [Connor] Twice.
- Twice and he bought back in sheepishly,
got annihilated again.
Connor was like,
"Oh, looks to me.
What's that?
I'm just too good."
(all laughing)
He was sipping his cocktail,
like, "See what I'm saying.
See what I'm saying."
And then I was biding my time,
I'd done quite badly and Connor was like,
"Come on, Chris,
you gotta step up your game, mate."
- [Joey] I know I think-
- I generally thought Chris
didn't know how to play poker
for the first hour,
just didn't do anything.
- And then I had a good hand,
I think it was like ace, king.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And I was like-
- That's a good hand.
- And I was putting some chips,
and Connor's like, "All in."
I was like, "Cool."
And Connor was like, "Aw, aw, aw, ro."
(Joey laughs)
- [Connor] I went exactly like that.
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
- And then I went, "What have you got?"
He went, "Nothing."
And then he lost.
He kind of decimated his pile,
and he's like,
"We should probably go home now then.
What do I say?
What is it?
What time does this place close?"
- This also wasn't for money.
There's some,
but there's a lot of places in Japan
where you can just gamble,
for fake money.
(Joey chuckles)
Which you can't buy anything with.
- So monopoly.
(Chris and Connor laughs)
- It's for show.
- [Garnt] So monopoly money then?
- Yeah monopoly money.
- I didn't know that,
the time, I thought we could get money,
we couldn't get money.
- I thought you could get
drinks or something with it,
but you can't get anything.
- [Joey] Like drink
vouchers and stuff right?
- Yeah but I think, no,
you couldn't get anything.
- Oh fuck.
- 'Cause I think even
drink vouchers is not
allowed, yeah.
- Okay.
- Really, yeah.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause there's a big poker
scene weirdly in Japan.
- Really?
- There is a bunch
of poker places in Shinjuku,
around the area.
Tons of different areas.
- Well, I mean,
there was talks of opening that casino
in Yokohama all right, recently.
And then the Yokohama government was like,
"No, actually."
(all chuckling)
"We need room for Pachinko machines."
- I think it would be good
for Japan to get casinos.
- I think so, yeah.
- Yeah.
- So they can realize
how shit Pachinko is.
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah.
- Get rid of these noisy fucking places.
- [Joey] It's the worst.
- Bro, the day they
introduce casinos in Japan
is the day Gacha dies.
(Chris laughs)
- [Joey] Yeah.
Or it levels up.
- Or it levels up.
- Depending on how you do it, yeah.
- All the playing cards won't
be your traditional king.
- (chuckling) Yeah.
- It'll be like anime waifus on it.
(Joey chuckles)
- Be like vice Schwartz cards.
(all laughing)
- It's like,
"Wonder what you mean,
you can win this thing called
money in chance machines.
That doesn't make sense."
- [Chris] No, that doesn't make sense.
- I'd like to imagine
that all the poker tables
are just themed after
the Yu-Gi-Oh arm things.
(Joey laughs)
It's like, "Hit me dealer."
(Joey speaks Japanese)
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
Goes on the thing.
- I would play poker
if I was keeping one of those,
that'd be sick.
- Bro, you don't win money,
you win life points.
- [Joey] Yeah, life points.
- How amazing is that?
- [Joey] You could exchange
life points for money.
(Connor makes a chiming sound)
(all laughing)
- So much hypocrisy in Japan with that.
Hypocrisy.
- So I don't understand how there can be
a big poker scene in Japan
if you can't win money.
I just-
- Well, I didn't know
that before I played.
I thought we're gonna walk
out here billionaires.
(Joey laughs)
And the guy was like,
"You've won, well done."
And he gave me some monopoly money.
I was like,
"Can I get a drink with this?"
He's like,
"No, you can't do anything, get out,
it's 1 AM."
- It's like you've won 1
million Zimbabwe dollars.
(Joey and Chris laughs)
You are now a millionaire.
- Please share.
- It's like 50 USD.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- I was pretty disappointed,
but I beat Connor and that was enough.
- [Connor] That was
enough for Chris to go.
- Well, now, the one
that you guys went to,
which is the same one that we went to.
- I did take you there afterwards.
- Yeah, you get monopoly,
it's like a block, right?
Like a plastic block you get
that you can exchange back to
play another round of poker.
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] Right.
So you win-
- So it's a scam.
- Yeah. (chuckling)
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- So what you win is just
the chance to compete again.
- Yeah, yeah.
It's like a play for free pass, basically.
(all laughing)
- So do you have to pay
to play in the place?
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
- [Joey] You have to buy in.
- We paid like 40 bucks to play thinking
that maybe we could get
a drink or something.
We didn't really,
I mean, to be fair,
it's on us for not knowing.
But yeah, no,
you can just play again in future,
if you happen to go back to the same bar
in the exact same place,
and you remember to
bring your piece of paper
that says you had money.
- Which I did.
- [Connor] Chris is-
- I used it to beat Joey.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] They probably go in there
for expecting someone to come back.
- We started playing poker,
and he was like three
times as many chips as me.
(Garnt laughs)
- It's 'cause it was-
- At the beginning.
- It was like four Japanese
men's all entire earnings
that I'd gotten then given to Chris.
(all laughing)
- So you can't even
exchange it for prizes.
or anything like that?
- Nothing.
- At least the Pachinko,
you can exchange it for prizes.
- Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
Right?
Surely.
- Yeah, surely if you could do Pachinko,
there must be some weird
work around where you can,
you could if you wanted to,
but maybe it's not worth it.
- [Chris] Well, that's what I saw.
- But I think the Pachinko one typically
is in another building.
Right?
- It is yeah.
- To cash out.
- You cash in your balls,
and then conveniently
just around the corner
there's someone that
wants to buy your balls.
And that sounds really wrong,
and I regret saying that now.
(all laughing)
And he'll buy your balls.
- Purchase your balls.
- He'll be like,
"What a coincidence I want those balls,
here's $500."
- I actually need ball
bearings, funny enough.
I've been starting my own factory.
Yeah, Pachinko is a strange thing.
- [Chris] I hate Pachinko.
- I feel like it's such a blight
on the countryside as well.
- [Chris] Oh yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Every countryside in
Japan is just depressed,
there's nothing, the business is dying,
except for the palace of Pachinko though.
It looks like it's like
the Montecarlo Casino
in the middle of the rice field.
It's ridiculous.
- Yeah, well,
that's the thing.
It's like, you know that a area in Inaka
is really fucking booming
when it comes economically,
because there's the Pachinko
parlor in the middle,
and then all the businesses
surround the Pachinko.
- [Connor] It is really sad.
- I've got like, brag,
I've got the number one
video on Pachinko, right?
(Garnt chuckles)
- Yeah.
- And you watch it,
and you just don't understand
why people play Pachinko.
I made it and I just don't get it.
- Can you play Pachinko?
I mean that-
(Joey laughs)
- We played it on my video.
- Well, we played it.
And I gotta say-
- I gotta say like-
- it's pretty fucking boring.
- I didn't really play it.
I've never felt like an IRL autoplay game
until I played Pachinko.
- Yeah, exactly.
- You turn a knob and that's it.
Is that game play?
Does that count as game play?
- It's like the subtle wrist movement.
- [Garnt] Oh, it plays itself,
it's brilliant.
- In the video though, I did,
I had Natsuki and he was like,
"I'm a professional,
I speak professional player."
I was like, "Really?"
And we gave him, I think,
like a 1000 balls,
and we had to see how many
he could get in half an hour.
And to be fair to him,
he did get like 4,000.
- Oh wow then.
- And he claimed that he had a strategy.
(Joey laughs)
Just luck as the strategy.
- Luck, luck.
- It's a 91 degree angle.
(Joey laughs)
Not a 90 degree angle.
- [Chris] It was bollocks.
- I'm sure there is,
but why is like, you
just get wrist cRamenps
after 10 minutes
of playing?
It's awful.
(Garnt laughs)
- [Joey] I don't get it, man.
- It's not fun.
I do not understand the fascination.
I feel like,
'cause it's the only form
of gambling they have,
so it just works.
- Oh, Gacha.
- That's not gambling,
you don't win money.
(Garnt chuckles)
- Well, you don't win money
in Pachinko either, right?
- You do.
- Yeah, you win prizes.
- You win prizes?
- No, you win money.
- No, you can't win money
in Pachinko.
- You can't win money.
- [Connor] Don't you get money?
- No.
- You can exchange the
balls for money, can't you?
- No, you can't.
Yeah, you can only it exchange for prizes.
Otherwise,
it becomes illegal gambling.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Yep.
- That's how they get around that.
- That's how they get around it.
- Pachinko isn't technically gambling,
because you can't win money,
you just win prizes.
Which you can
then exchange for money.
- Is that true?
- Yeah, you can win prizes.
- Can we fact search this?
I'm near certain
you can get money.
- You win prizes
which you then exchange for money.
- I know in the building itself
you can exchange for prizes.
But I know if you want money,
you have to go to the other building.
- [Joey] Right.
- I'm near certain.
- Yeah.
- So you can, in the building itself,
you can get like a bag
of crisps for 10 balls.
But if you wanna change
the balls for money,
you go to the other building.
- I always thought it
was, you get the balls,
you exchange 'em for prizes,
and then you go to another building,
and you can exchange the prizes for money.
- [Connor] No.
- I thought that was the work around.
- No, I'm near certain it's money.
Can we fact check this please?
- The debate of Pachinko.
- Well, because-
- Either way there is some legal loophole.
- [Joey] Yeah, there's a legal loophole.
- That is getting taken advantage of here.
- Because if-
- [Announcer] So it is illegal
to play Pachinko for money in Japan.
But there are loopholes
around Japan's street gambling laws,
some stemming from the
belief that the Japanese,
okay. (chuckling)
Once in a while, you have the-
- You can get money from Pachinko,
it is-
- Oh, no, no, you can get money
from Pachinko
- Yeah, you can,
but it's not a direct transfer.
- [Announcer] It's not a direct transfer.
- That's the loophole.
- Yeah.
(Connor and Garnt chuckles)
- It's illegal to win prizes
directly from the game,
but so that's where
the prize comes in.
- Yeah but you can get money.
- Oh no, you can get money.
- Yes.
But it's a loophole.
- You said you couldn't get money.
What do you wanna-
- No, no, no, you can't get money directly
from the machine.
- You can't officially
get money, right.
- I know, that's not what I was arguing.
I said, "You can get money from it.
You just go to the building outside."
- [Joey] But that's where
the loophole comes in, right?
- Yeah, that was never in contention.
- So, though, basically,
if they bring in a casino-
- Cut that bit out of the video.
(all laughing)
- [Connor] That is stupid.
- So basically if they
bring a casino to Japan,
they have to do the same thing,
unless they change the laws.
It's like you win blackjack
and you win a Teddy bear.
- Places have changed the laws before,
it's not beyond comprehension, I think.
- This is Japan, Connor.
(Joey laughs)
- [Announcer] Basically,
you get the amount of,
for example,
the receipt that says that
this is the amount that you get
for a certain token.
So this token,
you can't exchange it for
money within the city.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I see.
It's for money,
people aren't playing for toys.
Why'd you think people
would spend their whole life?
- I never said that.
- I know people who don't play for toys,
I know that there is a way to get money,
but I know that it's very much
in the gray area for like-
- That's why everyone's playing it.
(Garnt chuckles)
No one's playing it for a fucking plushy
for nine hours.
- Of course.
(all laughing)
- You never know some people might.
- Go to fucking E-Bay.
- I mean, there are people
who play crane games, right?
So it's pretty much the same thing.
- Can't understand those people.
- Well, actually,
you guys have all done the
crane game on YouTube, yeah.
- Don't let me talk about that
bloody crane game bollocks.
- I hate crane game.
- Yeah,
how much did you waste, Chris?
- I think, how much is it?
$500.
- Yeah and you got nothing.
- You might as just burn that for fun.
I'd have more fun just setting it on fire.
(Garnt laughs)
Than wasting my time trying
to catch that fucking monkey.
- This is a good transition
into what you think
about crane game.
- Shit,
awful, hate it, never again.
- I don't,
'cause I recently did it as
well on Connor's channel,
and I asked Connor.
I was like, "So how much
stuff did Chris win?"
And he's like, "Oh a bag of chips."
And I was like, "What?"
- No, I won at least two bags.
- Did he have arms?
- [Garnt] Oh yeah.
- He won two bags of chips
and he won a knockoff kettle.
(Joey laughs)
- And the reason was,
I didn't cheat like Connor,
I didn't ask the staff,
"I'm sorry, could I have some help?"
That was Connor and he's like-
- That's what you're supposed to do.
- That's boring,
I learned to play it by the rule book.
- Well, look what happened.
- I'm a man of honor,
I play by the rules,
I don't need help.
- They're not playing by honor.
Why should you?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- To be fair, I did win
though and the woman,
I was like, "Can I get my crisps out?"
And she had to remove it from the machine,
and she went, "Yeah, yeah, sure."
And then she just put
it back on the shelf.
(Garnt and Connor laughing)
And I was staring at her.
"Are you taking me for a mug.
What's going on?
Give my crisps."
And a supervisor had to come over,
"And be like, sorry, sorry,
he is a winner, give him his chips."
- (chuckling) He's a winner.
- I watched the footage back,
and it's quite funny.
'Cause there was a big sign on the machine
that said if it gets stuck,
where Chris has got stuck,
that you win the prize and
then you just put it back.
- Bastards.
(Garnt and Connor chuckling)
It was awful,
there was nothing fun about it.
Nothing about it.
- It's fun up to the first prize you win,
and then you just kind
of feel like a monkey
pressing buttons afterwards.
- And I was trying to get a monkey.
curious George or something, wasn't it?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Curious.
- Don't tell me you forgot.
- I can't believe
you just gave up on that.
- The machine took my money as well.
(Joey laughs)
So not only did my prize
get put back on the shelf,
even though I'd won it fairly.
I put in a $100,
just went up in smoke.
I had to get a woman over to
try and get the money out,
and while she was doing that,
I was still trying to catch
fucking curious George above her.
She was digging through the machine,
trying to get my money out like
a Indiana Jones excavation.
It was shit, I hate crane games.
I hate everyone that plays crane games,
I especially hate Connor
for making me do it.
Never, ever again, ever.
Ever.
- It was a good arcade though.
That Sendai one was my
favorite one, I think.
- [Chris] Biggest in Japan.
- I know, yeah.
- Did it have the best prizes?
- [Joey] No.
- I genuinely think the prizes were,
maybe the Taita one has the best ones.
- Yeah.
- I won the Ramenen maker.
- The shit kettle.
- And it's just a kettle.
(Joey laughing)
- It's a rebranded kettle.
It's like infringing
on copyright.
- It's kettle
where you put boiling water,
and then you just put your noodles in,
and they're like, "Ramenen kettle."
- So it's just a cup.
- Just like a bowl of shit.
- But it's got like a budget knockoff
of the Nissin cup noodle one.
- [Chris] It does, doesn't it?
- I mean, honestly the
favorite prize that I got
was my fucking home
Ramenen like TyRamenen.
- Oh really?
- It's the Ramenen.
That was my favorite prize.
- That's pretty cool.
- [Joey] Oh shit.
- It's cool just seeing the variation
of different machines that they have.
There was one that was
like a balance board,
in the one that we wanted.
- Oh yeah, there was.
- Was a balance board for a crane game.
So you move around with your
feet to choose where the crane.
It's awful.
- [Joey] Oh that's pretty cool.
- No, it's awful.
- [Joey] Is it?
- 'Cause you can't control
it to save your life.
- [Joey] Oh right.
- You just cheat and get
on the floor and move it.
- I can't think of any cool one.
I won Aloe hand cream for like 200 yen.
- [Garnt] Aloe hand cream.
(Joey laughing)
- I used one of the small
ones and I was like,
"I put in 200 yen and I
got this Aloe hand cream."
I was like, "Cool."
- Isn't there a better
way to spend $500, Connor?
- [Connor] Yeah, of course.
- Yeah, of course there is.
- I'm not doing it for a
smart financial decision.
I'm doing it for content.
- It's content.
- [Chris] Content.
- 'Cause people like
seeing you fail, Chris.
- [Chris] Yeah, that's true.
- To be fair, you crying at
curious George for 20 minutes
was a cathartic experience.
- They love seeing you get tortured.
- I think my blood
pressure went up that day.
(all laughing)
At one point I was in
a machine being like,
"Fucking piece of shit."
And I looked around,
there's like a little
kid just watching me.
(all laughing)
I was like, "Oh."
(Chris speaks Japanese)
- It came out so good,
'cause I felt it was probably
my strongest performance
as well.
And I was absolutely
murdering all these machines.
- But at that-
- And the dichotomy of Chris,
just struggling for his
life to get a bag of crisps.
- At that point,
you've done how many crane game machines?
Like three, four.
- You're a natural born
entertainer, Chris.
- You'd say that but the
one that I did with Joey
was by far the most difficult.
- Oh really?
- Oh, the Shinjuko one
was fucking so hard.
- It was tough, it was tough,
it was tough.
It was tough cranes.
- Although, I still got more than Chris.
- Would you say that there
is an actual technique to crane games,
now that you've done it like for-
- I figured out a technique.
- There is, there is.
- Okay, here's the thing, I think,
some machines,
the level of difficulty
isn't decided by the crane,
it's the size of the item they put in.
- [Joey] Yeah, right.
- There's some things that, like boxes,
some of the figure boxes, right?
They're just too big,
where they're just,
no matter where you push them,
they're gonna fall in,
and once they fall into like a-
- [Joey] Like a dent.
- It's like you can't get it out.
- Yeah.
- And so it's kind of, it's cool.
- You gotta reset it.
Otherwise it's not gonna work.
- And that's when you gotta
call the staff and be like,
(speaking Japanese)
Help me.
- And displace it sort of,
gradually pick it up and nudge
it slightly towards the edge.
- You are.
Again some boxes are so
big,
and so are not good at moving
that they'll just naturally
just fall into that
the moment you start moving them,
and they just hope you'd just give up.
- Yeah, I remember in my episode,
I asked the staff lady,
I was like,
"Is there like a technique of
any kind with any of these?"
And she's like,
"Oh, people who are really good at it
just figure out the physics."
- Figure out the physics.
- And I'm like,
"Cool, I have to be a physicist
to figure this shit out.
Amazing."
- You can maybe make a profit from it
if you're really good,
but it's just not worth it.
(Garnt chuckles)
Like why would you do that?
- Yeah, I remember when I
asked for advice in my video.
So the guy on the crane, he tells me,
"Oh, you gotta get it in this position."
Which was like the
position you do to like,
before it flips over.
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
- So he easily gets it into that position.
And then he's just like,
"Okay, so what you do after
you get it in this position."
Then he opens the box
and takes his hands out,
and he goes,
"You just flip it over
and it goes in the hole."
I'm just like,
"Brilliant.
All I need to do is fucking
just have a pair of keys,
and push it over with my hands.
Why didn't you tell me before?
What an easy technique."
(all laughing)
- I just got PTSD just
thinking about this.
- I thought Chris was just
playing it up for the camera.
- [Chris] No, yeah.
- But he was genuinely
furious after the video.
(Joey laughs)
He was just angry.
- There's something about exchanging
that amount of money and
just getting nothing,
nothing in return except stress.
- I got a bunch of stuff.
- You didn't, no, you didn't.
What you got was worthless.
- I got value.
I got maybe, at best
200 quid worth of stuff.
(helicopter buzzing)
- That's why I only
play rhythm games when I go to arcades,
'cause you get the experience you pay for.
- Massive helicopter.
- [Connor] AC30 going about.
- Come to take Connor away.
(Joey and Connor laughs)
Finally, back to Wales.
(Connor laughs)
Crane game, yeah, crane game.
(all laughing)
- A giant crane game.
- Drop him in the sea of Wales,
that's a place I just made up.
- Those videos come out way more fun
than they are to shoot,
that's for sure.
- It was like, what?
Four hour shoot?
- Yeah it's a rough shoot.
- It was just not fun.
- It was for the first hour and a half,
I thought, I was like,
"Oh this might be a decent video."
(Chris laughs)
And then the rest of the video,
it's like you just run out energy.
I'm just like, "What do I say about this?
What do I say?
Pushing the same button
for the thousandth time."
- The videos kind of really fun.
Really nice and easy to watch.
- What did you win?
Rem or something, wasn't it?
(all laughing)
- You remembered her name?
- R-E-M.
- Favorite band.
- One of my favorite clips-
- Shiny, happy people.
- One of my favorite clips of all time
is when he's getting
confused about Rem and Ramen,
and then I explained to him
that Ramen is her sister.
- So what?
Ramen?
- Ramen is her sister.
- Ramen is like a beast,
like a sheep, like a sheep.
(all laughing)
- Like a male sheep.
- Like a sheep or something, innit?
- You see a Ramen and you're like,
"That's a beast."
(Joey laughs)
- Do we have a Rem?
- No, we don't, actually.
- Do not.
- Wait, you never bought a Rem?
- No, we don't have her.
- [Announcer] No, no, it's-
- We don't have a Ramen.
- Why are they called Rem and Ramen?
Why not like something else?
- Bill and Ted.
- But are they from Japan?
Rem?
(Joey laughs)
- No,
they're fantasy characters.
- Ramen?
- They're from like, fuck, who knows?
- Who made this up?
Where are they from?
- Do you know any twins in real life?
- No.
- 'Cause the only twins
I know in real life,
the names are Hammy and Sammy.
- What?
- Are you serious?
- I swear to God, I swear to God.
- I don't know any twins
that have rhyming names.
- Yeah, I don't have any either,
rhyming names.
- What's the story of Rem and Ramen?
- Oh Rick and Roberto as well.
I guess that makes more sense.
- Rick and Roberto?
- I guess makes more sense
than Hammy and Sammy.
- [Joey] (chuckling) Hammy and Sammy.
- So we know, yeah,
we know stories.
- What's the story?
- What is Rem and Ramen about?
Where's the who?
- That's not the name of show.
(all laughing)
- Rem and Ramen.
I mean, is it a Japanese-
- Rem and Ramen's excellent adventures.
- It's a Japanese visual
novel and they got
turned into anime.
- Light novel.
- Oh yeah, light novel, sorry.
And got made into an anime,
and Rem and Ramen are-
- It's called Re:Zero.
- They're two maids and they're demons,
and they're very enjoyable characters.
- Why do you like it so much?
(all laughing)
- It's a good show.
- Why is it a good show?
- I like the characters.
- Why?
What do they do that
make you think, "Yes?"
- They're very caring
for the main character.
(Connor and Garnt laughs)
- It's like a son getting in trouble
by his dad.
- I feel like
I'm asking reasonable questions here.
What's the attraction to the show?
- It's hard 'cause you
didn't watch the show,
'cause there's a few scenes
with a specific character,
and Rem is just very endearing,
more so than most anime characters.
- She affable?
- Very affable in fact, yes.
- Not as affable as you, Chris.
- Not as affable as you, obviously.
- Japan hashtag.
- She gets rejected and it's really sad,
'cause she pours her heart out.
- Wow, spoilers. (chuckling)
- (chuckling) Spoilers.
- Everyone knows that now.
Everyone knows that.
- I gotta go,
and watch it now.
Where can I watch it?
- I don't know.
- [Joey] Online.
- Online.
- Legally online.
- Legally, legally.
- Always legal.
Great.
- Go and watch it, let
me know what you think.
- All right.
I'll watch at least one episode.
- Chris would not enjoy Re:Zero.
- People would pay good money
to watch you actually watch.
- (chuckling) Actually, yeah.
- People would pay an
exorbitant amount of money.
- You need to do a show
where you commentate over an episode.
- 'Cause you watching
non-Satoshi Kon anime
would be hilarious actually.
(Joey laughs)
- It's not perfect, believe me.
To be fair I re-watched,
you see, it's like low hanging fruit.
I watched Akira again for
the first time in years
the other day.
That was a beautiful film.
I forgot how amazing,
I mean, I know Akira's brilliant-
- Right behind you.
- Yeah.
- I was feeling emotional watching it.
I was like, "Yes."
- He's feeling emotional.
- "This is perfection."
This is like what everything
should be.
- It's so good.
- Yeah, it's amazing.
- So fucking good.
- The animation is fucking incredible.
- And that's where I need to,
I'm thinking sort of to
become like the Anime Man.
(Joey laughs)
I wanna get into anime a bit.
- I mean, it's free real estate right now.
- There's a gap in the market now.
- Yeah, there's a gap
in the market right now.
- So why don't you watch anime anymore?
(all laughing)
- Don't go into this.
- That's a good question,
that's a good question.
- Wait, you're the Anime Man.
- I don't wanna go into this, man.
- What-
- We've been into this before.
- So it's like you don't
watch it as much now?
- Yeah, pretty much.
- So I could be the new Anime Man?
- Please.
- All right.
- Fucking open a beer to watch this.
(Chris laughs)
- Yeah, I'll crack open
an Australian cider
that Chris brought.
- We cracking 'em open now?
All right.
- Chris brought some
Australian Three Oaks,
he brought some Three Oaks cider.
(cans clicking)
- It tastes just like home, gents,
tastes like home.
(cans clicking)
- These are actually pretty good.
They're better on top, but.
- Seeing a good job changing subjects.
Isn't it?
- Cheers, boys.
(Chris laughs)
- All right, cheers. (chuckling)
- Don't worry Chris,
I'll get you into anime.
(Chris laughs)
These two are posers.
(Joey laughs)
I'm the real anime fan.
- [Chris] Who's the most Anime Man here?
- The anime that he'll recommend
you will bore you to death.
- [Joey] Yeah.
Well, they're all reincarnation stories.
- You'll need a fucking flow chart
to figure out what's going on.
(Garnt laughing)
- So you know,
I did watch your anime review video.
I think it must have been
like two or three weeks ago
where you sort of had
your line up of things
you recommended watching.
That was quite interesting
'cause I was like,
"Oh you know, I wanna learn about anime."
- Yeah, I mean, I make them-
- Garnt's the man.
(all laughing)
- I can't take you
seriously when you say that.
(all laughing)
- I'm not joking.
- He was like,
"I wanna learn about anime."
- "I wanna learn about anime."
- It's like hearing my-
- My dad is telling me that.
- Yeah, it's like my dad is like-
- "Oh, I wanna learn
about this Minecraft thing
you're doing."
(all chuckling)
- "There's this thing called animation."
- "But I heard about these
things called let's plays."
- Garnt is like the good
one and I wanna hear
his thoughts.
(all laughing)
He's the voice of reason and credibility.
- Garnt is the good one.
- I'm the good one.
- He's the voice of reason.
And I thought if I
wanna learn about anime.
- Well, I mean you're
already into anime, right?
You like Satoshi Kon and Akira.
- Yeah, I love them.
- That's anime.
- But I mean just by watching four films
doesn't make me into anime.
- But there's a lot of
shows that are like that
in the same vein.
(Connor wails)
That I reckon you get into.
- Ghost in the Shell.
- [Garnt] I mean there's
no one that can replace-
- Low hanging fruit again.
- Yeah, I'm not saying it's
exactly the same or better,
but it's kind of in the same thing.
- [Garnt] The same vibes.
- Yeah, it's the same vibe, yeah.
- But I feel like I've neglected anime.
The reason I don't watch anime,
just 'cause growing up,
I didn't know anyone that watched it.
And there was no sort of way-
- Would you say
you had like a bad connotation
as well to watch anime?
To be honest.
- A little bit certainly
in the UK.
I think it's seen as like
a very geeky losery thing.
- I think everywhere back then,
it was like that.
- I don't think
that's fair at all.
- I mean, it's a lot different now.
Like we've said multiple times,
I think when we were growing up,
like our age group,
you'd get bullied for watching anime.
- Oh fuck yeah.
- But nowadays kids-
(Chris chuckles)
- Bullied for breathing.
(all laughing)
- Nowadays kids get bullied
for not watching anime.
For not watching certain anime.
- And I don't think that's good.
- It's the popular kids
who are watching now.
- All the popular kids are like,
"I love Naruto."
- Soon as you talk about
something you like,
filmography.
- Bully.
(Garnt laughs)
- Oh yeah but no,
I do want investigate a bit further.
- Investigate.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
You're saying this as if you're like-
- I want to dip my toes
into this anime business.
What do you recommend?
Based on what I know and like.
Like Ghost in the Shell,
Akira, Satoshi Kon.
Feed that into-
- Wait, have you seen Ghost in the Shell?
- Yes, of course.
- [Connor] You're like the iceberg meme.
- What, the movie?
- Not the live action.
- Oh no, that's shit.
- [Connor] This is
literally that tall iceberg.
- Don't talk about talk
about that silly film.
- I think he's watching
the best of the best.
- Yeah.
- If you're a degenerate,
the deeper you go down.
- I think you-
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah, well, that's how
you get someone into anime.
I think you'd really enjoy Baccano.
- Baccano.
- Baccano's good.
- That's like a good
entry level TV series.
- What happens?
- Okay, so it's kind of hard to explain.
- Like one sentence.
- All right, it's kinda
like a Quentin Tarantino,
Guy Ritchie film turned into an anime.
- That's good.
That's a good synopsis.
Good little line to get me in.
(Garnt chuckles)
- I say anything Narita Ryogo
makes is kinda like that.
Like Durara is also the same.
- That was a much more
exciting description
than what he said about
Rem and Ramen and Rom.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- Well, no, no,
I don't think you'll like Re:Zero.
- [Garnt] No.
- I have a suspicion you
might not like Re:Zero.
- [Garnt] You're not gonna like Re:Zero.
- You're not gonna like Re:Zero.
- The story, she is enduring.
Oh brilliant,
I don't want endearing,
I want Tarantino.
- They're not even the main characters,
that's the funniest thing.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- Who's the main character?
- Su-.
- Rom?
- Rom. (laughs)
- That is actually a character in Re:Zero.
(all laughing)
- That is a character.
- That is an actual character.
- I can predict anime.
I know anime without watching it.
- Yeah, he's the old guy who-
- Oh yeah.
- He's the old guy.
- Is he endearing?
- Kinda.
- He's kind of affable, yeah.
- (chuckling) Affable.
- Affable, affable, affable.
- That's the word of this podcast,
affable.
- What other anime
Chris might enjoy?
- I was thinking,
maybe, something like Red Line,
you might like.
(Chris snickers)
- What films do you like?
- Animation, yeah, but.
- Oh something, sci-fi, gritty,
a bit of something dark,
something sort of neo-noir.
- Psycho-pass.
- [Joey] Psycho-pass.
- Oh, yeah.
Cowboy Bebop too, maybe.
- Yeah.
- (chuckling) That's the
first one I thought about.
- Everyone says I would like Cowboy Bebop.
- I think you'd like Cowboy Bebop.
- Should I watch it on Netflix?
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
(all laughing)
- So, okay,
so there's two versions of
Cowboy Bebop on Netflix.
Go for the anime's version.
(all laughing)
- Did it get canceled?
- [Connor] (chuckling) It did.
- Yeah, season two got canceled, yeah.
- That's sad, innit?
Sad, sad that happens.
- Yeah, I think you'll
really like Cowboy Bebop and-
- [Connor] Yeah, Psycho-Pass,
I think you'd actually enjoy.
- Psycho-Pass,
I think you'd like Psycho-Pass.
- Psycho-Pass?
- Yeah, Psycho-Pass.
- It's a dystopian
future where you're rated
based on your mental health score.
- Sounds like real life,
Connor. (chuckling)
(Joey, Garnt and Connor laughs)
Dystopian future, that's now.
- Well, no,
it's like there's an all-knowing algorithm
that knows your mental health stability,
and if you are like
psychotic, it just kills you.
- Right.
- Yeah.
So it's kind of like-
- That's pretty fucked up.
- [Garnt] Yeah, of course.
- It's a fucked up show.
- [Garnt] That's the whole point of it.
- That's pretty exciting.
- And of course,
who's gonna do the killing,
but these enforcers,
and it's a pretty harsh
story where you follow
with these enforcers having to
basically just murder people,
and it's really fucking priceless.
- Yeah, it's really good.
- Sounds like my kinda thing.
- It's really good actually,
now that I think about it.
- They have this gun, right,
they have this gun and you
point it at the person,
and the gun scans what
their mental health is,
and if their mental health-
- [Joey] It quantifies
their mental health.
- Yeah, the gun goes from just stun gun
to just obliterating a
person to their atoms
based on how bad their mental health is.
- What's the gun called again?
It's annihilator or something.
- [Garnt] Dominator.
- Dominator, that's it.
- Is this like a feature
where the dislike button
was never hidden then?
(all laughing)
'Cause now it's gone,
my mental health is so
much better on YouTube.
But that's a cool premise.
- Yeah, it's a very cool premise.
- [Connor] You should watch it.
- Oh I'll watch it, yeah.
Psycho-Pass.
- Psycho-Pass.
- I actually think you'd
enjoy that actually.
- 'Cause If you're a psycho you pass.
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
Is that?
- I think it's more the opposite.
If you're a psycho, you don't pass.
- So it's Psycho Die.
- Psycho Die. (laughing)
- [Joey] Psycho Die.
- Feel really old and
out of the times now.
Help me get in.
- You should start titling anime,
Psycho Die, Ramen and Rem.
- Yeah, Rem and Ramen.
- Rem and Ramen.
- All right.
I'll get into it, I'll check it out.
- You'll probably enjoy
it more than new Matrix
that you were talking about.
- I feel like, yeah,
you are just more into
general films, right?
And cinematography.
- Perhaps.
- And staying up with the
news and stuff like that.
- But I think a lot of the
best cinematography comes out
of anime films.
Just watching Akira, the other day,
I was like,
"Holy shit, the cinematography
on this is brilliant.
The best of the best, 10 out 10."
So I kinda wanna go down
the anime rabbit hole.
- [Garnt] Yeah, I mean like do you-
- Explore a bit more.
- Do you still look at
films the same way now?
Or do you focus more on cinematography,
and just the general filmmaking craft?
- I still think I do look
at cinematography a lot,
but I still think
story's really important.
Like I just watched the Matrix Four,
Resurrections.
And it was all right,
it's very meta,
kinda comments on itself a lot,
and I'd recommend watching it,
but there's no sort of replay value.
I ask myself,
if a film is good,
I wanna rewatch it,
and if I don't wanna rewatch it.
I can't even say rewatch it.
If I don't wanna rewatch it
then it's not overly great.
- Right, right.
- I think you'd like One
Punch Man, weirdly enough.
- One Punch Man.
- I think you'd like it.
- I don't know.
- Really?
- I think so.
- I think anyone can enjoy One Punch Man.
- [Connor] I think you'd find it amusing.
- Yeah?
- And to be fair, the
cinematography is insane.
- But I think,
there'll come a point where
he'll watch One Punch Man,
and be like, "Oh this joke again."
- I mean I think you'd enjoy it.
I don't think it'd be
your most favorite anime.
- It's no Satoshi Kon.
- There is no Satoshi Kon.
- What did you say?
What did you fucking say?
(Connor laughs)
I ought to stick you in a
crane game machine head first.
- It's good popcorn entertainment.
- Yeah, popcorn.
- 'Cause I remember this weekend,
I finally saw Dune,
not in cinemas, unfortunately.
- [Chris] Oh no.
- So I didn't feel the sub woofers.
- You didn't feel the voice.
- Even-
- That film needs to be
watched in the cinema.
- Even watching it on my TV,
I felt like it was
getting bass out of the TV
that just didn't exist, man.
(Joey laughs)
Like, I dunno how it was possible.
- [Joey] Like a sub woofer was corned.
- That crappy $300 TV, I know,
'cause you have the same one.
That would not do it justice.
- I watched that at IMAX,
I nearly cried, my ears were bleeding.
(Joey laughs)
Like, "Brr."
Like Hans Zimmer but that was pretty good.
- But my God, the cinematography
in that was fucking insane.
- [Chris] Oh for one.
- Dune one is good if Dune two comes out,
and if it's good.
- [Chris] It is coming out.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah.
- But I mean is it gonna be good?
The Dune one was amazing
if Dune two is good.
- 'Cause it was weird,
'cause it didn't feel like
I was watching a movie,
it felt like I was
watching a HBO TV series,
something like that, it did.
When it ended,
it felt like it was an
end of an episode rather
than just an end of a movie.
But it wasn't necessarily bad.
- I didn't really like the ending,
and I hate, oh, I don't
know if it spoils it,
but just by saying the last line,
the film, where she's like,
"This is just the beginning."
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
I was like,
"No, don't say that."
That's like, "There's a storm coming."
That sort of shit line
you see in so many films.
- I mean, to be fair, it is
based off a sixties book.
- (chuckling) Yeah.
- You have to take that
into consideration.
- But other than that.
- Seven, eight outta 10,
I feel it deserves it.
- How much?
- Seven, eight outta 10, I feel.
- Maybe a 8.5.
- I'd give it like an eight or a nine.
'Cause the story just picks
up from there as well.
Like if you've read the books,
but, yes, I'm looking forward to it.
- It was just like my kind
of story where it just set up
the world really well.
- It did, yeah.
- I was more interested.
Like I watched the film,
and then I just went on a binge
of just lore explanation videos.
'Cause I'm just like there are
so many interesting aspects
of this world that they just kind
of didn't have time to explore.
- Frank Colbert was not stupid,
I don't know how he did it.
- Well, it's like how old's the book now?
Like fucking-
- First book was 1964.
- [Connor] My God.
- Can I spoil one thing in it?
Could we do a spoiler warning?
- Okay, sure, spoiler warning.
- Spoiler.
One thing I really didn't
like about the film
is that they had this
really, so again, spoilers.
Please watch Dune.
Please, if you haven't.
(Joey chuckles)
Especially like a really impactful scene
where he kills someone for the first time.
- [Joey] Yeah, that was very good.
- But then it's supposed
to be a really big deal,
but they just bring it up at one second
before he kills someone
for the first time.
They're like,
"By the way, he's never killed anyone."
Starts stabbing a man
to death and it's like,
"Oh, don't really think
that was that difficult."
- [Chris] It's, yes,
bit anti climatic, yeah.
- I wish they'd built
it up from the start,
other than that, it's the
only gripe I had with it.
- Well, it's a strange film,
'cause the big set pieces
happens halfway through
rather than at the end.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- And I felt a little bit,
I'm all for changing up the sort of story,
and doing something a little bit original,
but I felt like payoff at
the ending was like, "Oh."
- Well, I don't think you'd
think it needed a big set piece.
That wasn't the highlight for me.
'Cause actually I was
so immersed in the world
that when it went to the big set piece,
I was like,
"Can we just go back to small shit?"
Like I just-
- Oh yeah, no, I'd love that,
the political aspect is really cool.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, it was.
- One of those films that I was bored
for the first 40 minutes,
and then after I'd kind of sat
through all the good stuff,
I was like,
"Actually now I want more
of this start boring stuff."
- [Joey] (chuckling) More talking.
- But I wonder that's why
when you're making it,
is it hard to see it from
a perspective of someone
who doesn't know anything
about the lore of Dune?
How do you do it when you
already know so much about it,
and how good the lore is?
And how do you explain it
in a way that's engaging?
Because I do think, I
don't know if you were,
but I was bored for the first 40 minutes.
Just waiting for something to happen.
- I wasn't.
- No, I wasn't.
- I don't know, maybe I'm-
- Well, it was pretty engrossing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It kind of reminded me of,
gonna mention it again, Joey,
Arcane, where the first two episodes,
nothing really, technically happens.
- Oh I want Chris to watch that, actually.
He'd love it.
- What's that about?
- Oh, you should-
- Summarize that in a line.
(Garnt laughs)
- If you go to that side, I'm truly alone.
- Have we gone a week
without mentioning it?
- No, I actually wanna-
- I legitimately want someone
to make one of those things
where it's like,
"It's been blank days since
Arcane was mentioned."
(Garnt laughs)
And just rip it off every week.
- You gotta watch it, it's amazing.
- Amazing, amazing, shit.
- I haven't seen it.
- He hasn't seen it.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
Amazing.
- Wasn't it like one of the top shows
of IMDB?
- [Chris] What's it about?
What's it about?
- How would you explain it Garnt?
You're clearly better at this.
- It's about League
of Legends.
- In one sentence.
- League of Legends.
- Again.
- One sentence.
There's no way I can just
describe in one sentence.
- League of Legends.
- You have to.
- It's just a very engrossing world
that's kind of like-
- [Joey] Just say what it is,
it's League of Legends.
- It's League of Legends.
- It's based off of the game, sort of,
not really though.
- No.
(Joey laughs)
- [Connor] No, no, no.
I know, I know, I know, I know.
- Raid of Shadows again.
(Joey laughs)
- It's not, it's not.
Just give it a watch,
give it a chance,
the animation is insane.
- How would you describe
Dune in a sentence?
Outta curiosity.
- [Announcer] The shit.
(all laughing)
- Very good.
- Imagine Star Wars but good.
- [Announcer] Whoa.
(all laughing)
(Joey and Chris celebrates)
- I love Star Wars,
but there's only two films
in the series that are good.
The first one,
the second one that came out 1977, 1980.
- Oh wait.
- And then everything else-
- So episode four and five.
- Yeah.
- When you say first and the second,
I thought you meant episode one and two.
(Chris chuckles)
- I was like,
"Crap, dude, Jesus Christ, dude."
- I love the first and second film,
all the prequel memes.
- Oh, yeah, they're pretty good prequel.
- Prequel memes are the best memes of all-
- The third one's all right,
but yeah, Dune is like,
imagine Star Wars but good.
- I actually agree with you.
I-
- Like the characters-
- am really not a fan
of Star Wars at all.
- You know what the best
thing about Star Wars was?
The Lego games.
That was the best thing about Star Wars.
(Joey chuckles)
- To be fair, they were pretty good.
- They were fucking amazing games.
Dude, they were so good.
- I haven't
played all of them,
but the first one was so good.
- Dude, I remember I had the act,
I think it was four to six movies.
It was the trilogy,
and that was my only
experience for the movies
for the first 10 years of my life.
(Joey laughs)
And I used to fucking love it.
I just loved getting
those fucking Lego pieces.
- I think the only thing
I liked about episode one
was the pod racing scene.
- Go, go.
- [Connor] Now this is pod racing.
- That's the worst bit.
- What?
- No, no.
- The lightsaber scene,
the lightsaber.
- Oh the fight, yeah.
With Darth Maul.
- Darth Maul.
- Oh yeah, the Darth Maul
scene, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Darth Maul was like the best villain.
- Yeah, Darth Maul was the best villain,
you're right, you're right.
- I feel like this is
the series of shit takes.
(Joey laughs)
- Let's just stop, let's just
stop talking about Star Wars,
we clearly don't know our shit.
- And as from a normie perspective,
I thought it was all right.
- I think the problem was
I did like Star Wars a lot,
but then the new films came out,
and destroyed everything and it was-
- I haven't seen any of the new ones.
- It's so fucking boring.
- I watched Rogue One.
I watched Rogue One.
That was-
- Rogue One's all right.
- Yeah, I quite like Rogue One.
- 'Cause that sort of, I mean,
if you're a fan of the
original Star Wars film,
ties in nicely.
I didn't care about the
characters when they died.
I was like. (chuckling)
(Joey and announcer laughs)
Darth Vader's in it,
so it's good, innit it?
There's some cool scenes in it
that call back to the original,
and I like that.
But the new film's just shit.
Oh, the characters-
- I thought the first film
had potential and then it just
lacked coherent direction,
I thought.
- Well, they just sort of
made up as they went along.
- Yeah, that's what it felt like.
- What's that Chinese whisper
game where you write a line,
fold it and move it on?
It was like that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Do like Ryan Johnson?
I love Ryan Johnson,
but no, there was no coherent strategy.
It failed.
- It was never gonna please
what the fans wanted.
They had such lofty expectations.
- True.
- Well, it's just funny as well.
- They back pedaled, didn't they?
On the last one, they were like,
"Just do whatever the fans want."
And it was just really,
really bad.
- That's cause nothing was set up.
Everything was set up,
Ryan Johnson tore it down,
did his own thing,
and then they were like, "No, no."
- That would've worked though
if they'd had another
follow up to that, maybe.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- But it wasn't.
It was like.
- I think, definitely,
the second film depended
on the third film following
on from what he had set up.
But obviously-
- I mean,
it was just telling that,
I remember how much hype
there was for episode seven.
Like it was fucking everywhere.
- Well, episode seven
was pretty well received.
People loved it.
- Yeah.
- Well, of course-
- But then every subsequent
film was just less,
and less talk about it, right.
- And then eight,
everyone was like, "Oh no."
"Oh no."
(Joey chuckles)
- And I didn't hear anything about nine.
- That's because-
- What happened
to number eight?
- Because they set up eight so badly.
- All right, yeah.
- Oh yeah, Carrie Fisher,
she flew in, didn't she?
- And then it gutted
John Boyega's character.
- Princess Leia flew
through space.
- What? (chuckling)
- They gutted
John Boyega's character.
- I thought you
were gonna say,
"Oh Carrie Fisher, she passed the away."
(Joey laughs)
- I was like, "What?"
- Princess Leia, Princess Leia.
I forgot the characters name.
Flew through space, it
was a bit weird and-
- In a spaceship or?
- And then they're
at a point where-
- The worst bit?
- The spaceship went to light speed,
and it just fucking kamikazed it's way
through another Death Star,
or something.
- Do you like it when they-
- And it wasn't a Death Star,
I don't know what the name of the ship is.
- Make it Destroyer.
- Destroyer. (chuckling)
- Death Star.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- I could feel the Star
Wars fans just perk up
when I said Death Star there.
- But the worst bit was the
opening, like five minutes,
I knew it was fucked.
'Cause there's a scene,
I dunno if you've seen it,
but there's a, your mum joke in it.
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's like, the main
villain's there and he's like,
"Destroy the planet."
And this guy's like,
"Got a message for your mum."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I'm not even fucking making this up.
Go and watch it.
And I was like, "No."
- Is that episode seven?
- They tried to get
that Marvelesque humor,
and shove it into Star Wars
and it just ruined everything.
- It's those insipid one liners.
- And it's like, "I've got
a message for your mum."
I'm not even making this up.
(Joey laughs)
I could have written that in the script,
and it's just so bad.
(Chris wails)
- What do you think
about them using actors
that have passed away?
They're just putting them in the films.
- As long as it's done
tastefully, I don't mind it.
- Something weird about it, isn't there?
- When you die,
I'm gonna use you.
- Fuck.
(Joey laughs)
- CGI Cdawg.
- Even if they're like,
"Yeah, keep using me."
I think it is just strange.
- I mean, I feel like it depends
on the manner that it's done.
There's a difference between putting
in our beloved character in
their beloved franchise, again,
as like a cameo or something.
And then there's using
a dead man's Twitter
to promote an NFT.
- Oh my God.
- Oh God.
- That's you know-
- I just feel like Disney
is not the company you want
being in charge of when dead
people can keep being in films.
(Connor laughs)
I feel like Disney's gonna be like,
"No, Harrison Ford hasn't died yet."
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
"He's gonna keep-"
- [Joey] Still alive and well,
look at him.
- "We have a signed note that
says he wants to keep being
in Star Wars infinitely."
(Connor laughs)
- [Joey] It's got a signature on it.
- "We have the estate of
Harrison Ford agreeing
that we want to keep him
being Han Solo for life."
- You can tell immediately though,
when it's done in a milking manner though.
And like-
- [Connor] I don't know.
- I feel most fans
immediately can recognize.
They're like,
"Yeah, that's not a cash grab."
- It worked in Rogue One, I think.
With Grand Moff Tarkin and Princess Leia
for just a brief moment.
- I just don't want it
to become a common thing
that is used very often.
- Yeah.
- Just feel like it'll get a little weird.
- When have you seen it and thought,
no, this is not good?
- It's not that I've seen
it and it's not good.
I'm like,
"Oh no, people are gonna take
this too far at some point."
Just make the whole film
with a man who's dead,
because their estate signed, said sure.
And it's like.
- [Chris] It will happen.
- I know it will.
- But it's soon.
- That's why it's kinda. (wailing)
- I mean, the music industry's
already fucking there.
Like with all these
fucking posthumus albums
that are just horrible.
- How would you feel though?
Like, you know, 10, 15 years
if you die and then you're the Connor-
- (chuckling) Only 10, 15.
- I don't know.
(Joey laughs)
His cholesterol's pretty bad.
(all laughing)
As we've seen.
- You know, the Connor estate's like,
"We want to keep Connor's-"
- I don't know.
- "Connor would've loved to been
in more videos in crane games."
- Something-
- [Chris] "Join him in."
- There's something sad about art
when you just have to bring
people back from the dead
to keep making it.
You know what I mean?
- Mm.
- Why can't we just-
- Just get a new you?
- Have art just continue to
blossom with new generations.
- How I felt about The
Matrix Four. (chuckling)
But-
- But obviously it's
when corporations know
that they can keep, you know,
'cause they're already trying
to rehash much as they can.
The last thing I want is
that they can get the rights
to people's likeness and then
just start reproducing film
with them.
- But then I don't think I'll
be commercially successful.
I think if someone does go all the way,
then no one's going to fucking watch it.
Right?
- Or they'll be just ridiculed off
the industry.
- I feel like we've said
that about so many things
in our life and here we are.
And you know, I dunno, I feel, I dunno.
- I would like to grasp
hope and think that,
you know-
- [Garnt] Grasp.
- [Connor] I dunno.
- Grasp at the hope that
maybe people have a sense-
- I agree in some ways,
but then NFTs exist.
(Chris laughs)
- That's true.
- There's not enough hope.
- Yeah, you're right.
- You got a lot of people.
- We are living
in a dystopian future.
- You're correct
in that sense.
Once everyone becomes NFT bros,
that's it.
- I mean, yeah, look what
they did to fucking Stan Lee.
What was that?
- I thought it was a
parody account at first.
- [Chris] Who posted it on his account?
His family or something or?
- Someone with access,
I guess.
- So if go you back
into Stan Lee's Twitter,
this isn't the first thing that,
that Twitter account has promoted.
So obviously someone got him
to sign some fucking documents
before he passed away.
Just giving them rights
to basically everything.
- Yeah, 'cause you can
control some of the stake.
So you can be in control
of everything, basically.
And it's pretty-
- Yeah, it's pretty fucked.
- Distasteful.
- It's pretty fucked.
You know?
What's next?
Like Stanley deep fakes?
(Joey laughs)
Where he promotes the newest
crypto coin or something.
- Where he's at your local con?
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
Jesus Christ.
- Yeah, it is getting very,
very black mirror esque,
you know.
This is some shit you'd see
in a black mirror episode,
except it's unfortunately
happening in real life.
- I mean, I think in our lifetime
there'll be technology where they
could go through every video we've made,
and create an avatar,
digital avatar of us that looks,
and sounds like us, has the same-
- [Garnt] Deep fakes.
- Already have a-
- Yeah,
but have a full AI, sort of,
synthesized version of say Connor, right.
So you send AI to watch every
CdawgVA con, God forbid.
(Joey laughs)
And listen to all the podcasts.
You can get his voice,
you can get his mannerisms,
his personality and create a sort
of AI Cdawg.
- Have you been playing?
Have you not heard the Garnt AI voice?
- What?
What?
It exists already?
(Connor chuckling)
- I haven't even heard that before.
- You haven't heard it?
- No, no.
- Oh my God.
- We're already there.
(Garnt laughs)
20 years ahead of schedule.
- The future is now, Chris,
the future is now.
- The future. (chuckling)
That's the title of the podcast episode.
(Garnt laughs)
The future is now, we're all fucked.
- Chris thought he was making a-
(Joey chuckling)
- A futuresque.
- A futuristic-like video,
or he was just making a segue.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- God damn it.
- What do you want Garnt to say?
- I love Chris Broad.
- Oh God, don't do that.
- Let me just sign up.
I'll just fucking sign up.
- You have to sign up?
Oh wow.
- What is this website then?
- I dunno what the
ethical requirements are
to use Garnt's voice and synthesize it.
- Did you give permission for this?
- I did not give any permission.
- Oh my God.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
That was dark as fuck.
- Well, there's hours and hours
and hours of audio from us.
- Wait, are you guys on there?
- I'm not.
- Why am I on there?
(Chris laughs)
- Wait, am I on there?
- No.
- Okay.
Just Garnt. (laughing)
- Why specifically me?
- I'm pretty worried.
- You have the least amount of videos out
of all three of us.
- We've all talked an equal
amount on Trash Taste.
What's going on?
- So if we murder Garnt now,
we can have Garnt on the
phone instead. (chuckling)
(Garnt laughs)
- Isn't that impressive?
- Just in front of the mic.
- Just put up cardboard cutout of Garnt.
- Trash Taste discontinued.
- Yeah.
- It's like, no.
- There he is.
- A blow up. (laughing)
A blow up doll with just
a phone strapped to it
with Garnt's face on it.
(Joey laughs)
- That's terrifying, isn't it?
- The year is 2030,
all of Trash Taste episodes
are now auto generated.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- You like boning shit?
What the fuck?
(all laughing)
- But aye, but aye.
- Yeah,
'cause one of my videos,
I made like a AI system that
could auto generate some anime,
and light novel titles and it got
to the point where-
- Pretty spot on.
- It's scarily accurate.
- These boys couldn't tell the difference.
- Like Psycho-Pass?
- [Garnt] Huh?
(chuckling) Yeah.
- Something like that, right?
- Something like that, yeah.
- Something like that.
- And now they've
released newer updated AI
that cannot only make titles,
but actually write a
full on writing prompt,
write a first chapter of a story.
- [Chris] That's pretty-
- It's all getting pretty insane.
- [Chris] Jesus.
- And-
- I'm trying
to get it working.
- Where's his voice?
As promised.
- The fucking sign-up,
Jesus Christ.
- Why Garnt?
Why only Garnt? (chuckling)
- Are you offended that
you're not on it, Joey?
- No, I'm just wondering
who else is on there.
- Why not me?
- Who else is on there?
- There's quite a lot
of YouTubers on here.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- I bet I'm not there.
- You've made it, Garnt.
- Let's have a look.
- I don't have to-
- You're AI now.
- I don't have to record an
anime review again in my life.
(Chris, Joey and Garnt laughs)
- No, no, no, the-
- The Garnt AI can link
up with the script AI,
and just make a video.
- [Garnt] Yeah, exactly.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Let's put this on.
- Should do a phone call to Sydney,
and see if she can
determine the difference.
(moderate music)
- Hold on, it's synthesizing.
- Okay.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Synthesizing.
- No, I can't say what I typed.
- Oh God.
- Connor's like, "It's a,
it's a progRamen I wrote."
(Joey laughs)
- Oh it's made it, here we go.
- All right.
- I love Chris Abroad in a man.
(Garnt laughs)
- (chuckling) Wait, what did you say?
- I heard what he said.
- What he say?
- It doesn't need to be repeated.
- I love Chris Abroad in a man.
(Joey laughs)
- I love Chris Abroad-
- I love pizza bread.
- I love Chris Abroad in a man.
(all laughing)
Cringe, cringe.
- I love Chris Abroad in Japan.
- [Chris] I'm subscribing.
(Garnt laughing)
- The first voice is, "I love Chris."
That bit sounded Garnt, actually.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The, "I love Chris."
- Other than that it went like-
- I love Chris Abroad in a man.
(Connor laughs)
- Abroad in a man.
- I hear, "I love Chris,
a bread in a man."
- Yeah.
(all chuckling)
- That's interesting.
- [Garnt] That is interesting.
- The future's luckily a bit
further away than I thought,
suck it.
- Well, it also depends on
how much reference they have.
'Cause they have a SpongeBob
voice that I swear to God
is like a hundred percent accurate.
- [Joey] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Jesus.
- They have Chill's as
well, it's really spot on.
(Joey laughs)
Your favorite.
- Not really hard, is it?
- "Number 10, Burger King, foot lettuce."
(Chris chuckles)
- "The last thing you want
in your Burger King burger."
(Joey chuckles)
- "They went too far."
(Joey and Announcer chuckles)
Fucking hell.
- I hope I'm back on that channel.
- One day we'll have to
do something scarefest.
- It's the biggest honor when Chill
says your YouTube channel, man.
- I think that fucking shipyard
we go to is scary enough.
- [Chris] Shipyard?
- It was awful.
- Oh was it?
- Awful.
- [Chris] Shipyard.
- Shipyard.
- A branch touched
Connor's leg and he's like,
"It's a snake, I swear."
(Joey and announcer laughs)
And then he runs off.
- Something ran over my leg.
- You can watch the video, slow it down,
you see it's a twig.
And he's like,
"Oh gosh, there's a snake or something."
- You can't see it's a fucking twig.
- It's a twig.
- You weren't even pointing
at my foot.
- It's a twig.
Twig.
- Chris just wants me
to be a little bitch.
- And then there's the spiders,
"Oh, I'm gonna die."
(Joey chuckles)
- That spider was big.
- Spider, awful.
(Joey laughs)
- That spider was big.
- Were you allowed to film there?
(Connor laughs)
- It's kind like public access,
you just walk through it, yeah.
- There's no sign that says, "No."
- You know, if there's a no
entry sign you always obey them.
- There's a lot of them that say no entry.
- [Garnt] Right, right.
- Don't go in there.
We did actually go to one
that was like, "No entry."
So be careful.
- It says, "Don't enter."
But it doesn't say, "Don't film."
(Joey and Chris laughing)
That's the Pachinko loophole, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(Garnt laughs)
- I figured if there's no
sign saying you can't go in,
and it's publicly accessible, I mean.
- There was no walls or anything.
We didn't climb a fence.
- No, it was literally
just like you're on a road,
there's like, patch of grass,
you just walk into the
grass and you there.
So Chris, it's been a good
year for you, you'd say.
- Somebody-
- You made a lot of videos.
- Well, somebody sent
me message being like,
"On the Trash Taste podcast
at start of the year,
your new year's resolution was
do something crazy and wacky,
and you got the studio
and you met Ken Watanabe.
- Yeah, that's pretty crazy, wacky.
- I'm pretty happy with how the years
have got wacky.
- Got wacky weekends.
- We made wacky weekends, I was gonna say.
I thought that's what you-
- You have it in the name.
- I was like, "Wow, we're
left to high and dry, though."
- Yeah.
- Everyone's like, "When you
doing something with Garnt?"
And so that's my-
- When are we doing something,
Chris?
- 2022.
- New year's resolution, 2022.
- 2022, man, 2022.
- I wanna do a six part
travel series with Garnt
called Taken for Garnted.
(all laughing)
And. (chuckling)
(hands clapping)
- Have you been writing these jokes?
Just writing them all down?
- No, I'm just a genius.
- Prepared that three months ago.
- He's been waiting to
say that, I can tell.
- I want abuse Garnt through
physical activity. (laughing)
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
I wanna climb Krakatoa with Garnt,
I wanna go to-
- [Garnt] Krakatoa.
- Just do it crazy, like, yeah.
- Chris abusing my body,
taking me to Wanko soba.
(Chris laughs)
- Wanko soba.
- He got the video demonetized.
- It's awful.
- Wanko soba.
- What horrible-
- That doesn't sound like a dish,
it sounds like something
you do every night.
(Chris chuckles)
- An awful experience, that's what.
- Wanko soba. (laughing)
- Is that how it's pronounced?
Or is that just how-
- No, it's just him
butchering their language.
- It's wank soba.
- There's still wank in there.
It's wank, it is wank.
- 'Cause we went to a bar
with Jan the other day,
and he goes, "Chris
just made me wank soba."
And I'm just like, "Shit, sober?
What's going on?"
- It was shit.
(Garnt laughing)
No, it's all right,
we loved, we loved it.
It was good, just too much.
But I was like,
"Why do I have to ruin my body
for your fucking channel, Chris?
How about we ruin my body for my channel?"
- I did.
- Oh yeah.
- You put me on a stupid ferry.
- He ruined his mind for
you getting curious George?
- Yeah, on the crane game.
- Curious George, PTSD,
high blood pressure.
And then like I did a ferry.
He was like, "Oh there's a a ferry,
it's really good."
We're the ferry, shit.
(Joey laughs)
And I got really seasick.
And I had to lie down the entire shoot,
otherwise, when I stood
up, I was like, "Blur."
- He was in a horrible mood.
- At least my videos, they're fun.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
Going to an abandoned shipyard
at 1:00 AM, freezing cold.
- Who wouldn't wanna do that?
- That sounds fun.
- Do you wanna go to
an abandoned shipyard?
- Fuck yeah, that sounds fun.
- Yeah, super fun.
Taken for Garnted, coming soon.
- How long did it take
you to think of the name,
Wacky weekends?
Where'd that come from?
- That was like the-
- Where'd that come from?
- I said it as a joke.
I was like-
- You couldn't think of a better one.
- We do something wacky on a weekend,
Wacky weekend.
- Probably around the same time as it
took the Anime Man to be formed.
(all laughing)
As in five seconds.
- Nothing else worked
though, that was snappy.
- Yeah.
Wonder weekends first.
- Wicked weekend.
- Chris and Connor.
- I think Wacky weekend kinda works.
- The Chris and Connor show.
- Chris and Connor Abroad in Japan.
- Chris nearly fucking killed
me on the bridge as well.
That bridge was so dangerous.
That was actually so dangerous.
- Yeah, that was pretty ropey.
- Fun?
This poor kid nearly died on that bridge.
- Went to that,
the worst hotel in Japan,
I still actually-
- Oh God.
- I think that is the worst
thing I've done this year.
And I've done a lot of horrible shit.
But the sets over an active volcano.
- It's a volcano.
- This hotel we went to,
I still can't get the smell
of that room out my head.
- I wish you were there,
'cause you should have
seen the three hours
of Chris just being like,
"We got a stay, haven't we?"
And I'm like, "No."
- If you watch the video,
you can see our eyes go red
over the period of the shoot.
The air is just filled
with 48 kinds of mold.
- It's mold.
Are you asthmatic like me, right?
- Yeah, yeah. (laughing)
- I'm amazed I made it
outta that room alive.
I was like.
(Chris gasping)
Towards the end.
- We filmed, right,
and I was like, you know,
obviously we'd already paid for the room,
but it was such a state where I was like,
"We should get another
cheap hotel that isn't bad.
'Cause why stay here?"
And Chris was just like,
"I think we should stay here."
I'm like, "For what reason, Chris?"
- Content.
- Well, even though I was dying,
there's something still awkward
about going down to a hotel
after two hours and be like,
"Oh we gotta go now, bye."
- And it's not that Chris was
worried about the content.
We already got the content,
we filmed the room.
He just didn't want to
go and confront the staff
that we were checking out.
- [Joey] Oh right.
- And I was like, "I'll fucking do it."
He's like, "No, we can't
do that, it's rude,
it's rude."
- Man of honor.
That's respectful.
- And I'm like,
"All their clientele here are
checking out after one hour.
Why do you think that is?"
- [Joey] That's true, yeah.
- All coming and going.
- Well, I discovered that night we did,
we actually checked.
- Sure it wasn't the mold
that was in the air?
(Garnt and Chris laughs)
- There was blood on the wall as well.
- Oh God.
- There was blood on the wall.
- Though under the bed right-
- One giant blood stain
on his mattress.
- They hadn't hooved it around the bed,
they just hooved it under the bed.
And if you lifted the beds in the videos-
- [Connor] Massive piles of dust,
massive layers.
Like the last layers-
- How's this still
in operation?
- I think, I dunno.
- It's a money laundering
something I think.
And then we tried to check
into another hotel and in Japan
we discovered that it's really
hard to check into a hotel
past sort of 11, 12 PM.
- The hour of our hotels.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And the staff were really angry
at this nice hotel we tried to get in.
They were like, "What do you want?"
We're like, "A room for the night."
They're like, "No, we can't do it."
And then they were just
being really dicks about it.
- Yeah, we were like, "Can we
have a room with two beds?"
And they were like,
"No, we don't have one."
Then we're like, "How about
two rooms with one bed?"
And they were like, "Okay, yes."
- That's, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it was like, "All right,
well, I guess we won't
pay you then, I guess."
It was really strange.
I understand, it's probably
inconvenience, but what?
- [Joey] Definitely.
- I mean you're in the service industry.
- Yeah.
- Literally.
- The person-
- Can't wait for Japan, really.
- Person at the one star
hotel was more affable
than the people at the four star hotel.
And that's the irony.
The person was actually quite nice.
Affable.
- They were like, "Oh my God,
people actually stay here."
(Chris laughs)
- Oh my God, money.
- "What the fuck?"
- A customer.
- It was a really sketchy area as well.
Very seedy.
- Well, you don't have a hotel like that
in a fucking uptown area.
Do you?
- Yeah.
(Joey laughs)
- But it's so hard to talk about this
without sounding like a fucking snob,
but it was really just awful.
It was so bad.
- Well, I mean, it's
the worst hotel, right?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Of course.
You're not gonna be like,
"Yeah, it was lovely,
it was accomadatable.
- It was the worst hotel.
- There's always someone like
that in the comments though,
it's like, "You got a roof over your head,
it's more than most."
And it's like, "Fuck off, mate."
This roof over my head's
gonna kill me in one hour.
(Chris laughing)
Fuck off.
(all laughing)
- It's the first time
being in a hotel room,
and actively worried
about my physical health.
That's quite a weird sensation to-
- I was googling, "How many
types of mold are there?"
And I was going around
the room spotting 'em all,
things like that.
- If there's mold in the room,
you should probably leave
as soon as possible.
But the kicker was when Connnor
pulled the blanket back,
and it was just a big
patch of blood on my bed.
- What happened?
- And I was like,
"Oh it's time to go."
You can't sleep in a pool of blood.
- It looked like either
somebody was stabbed,
and they were bleeding on the bed or-
- [Joey] Or someone
missed the time of month.
- I think, yeah.
Looks like that.
- [Joey] Yikes.
- It was-
- [Joey] Either way, no thank you.
- Yeah, I would also get out.
- Taken for Garnted.
Are you ready?
(Garnt laughs)
- Did I find that hotel?
Did I find that hotel or did you find it?
- [Chris] Huh?
- Did I find that hotel
or did you find it?
- I can't remember.
- 'Cause I remember,
I found a ton of other ones.
- Tried to wipe it
from my head like a
neutralizer from Men in Black.
I want it out.
(Joey laughs)
The only evidence is that video.
I don't wanna remember that.
- 'Cause we found a ton
of hotels in Shikoku
that looked really bad.
- [Chris] Bleak.
- Really, really rough hotels.
- But-
- Because I think no one stays there.
- No.
- But I wanna see some Trash
Taste specials next year
where you guys go in those sort of places.
(Connor laughs)
- Why those places?
We gotta do exciting
things, Chris, come on.
- People wanna see torture, pain.
- There's more interesting ways to-
- Trash Taste Guantanamo.
(all laughing)
Torture.
- I'll watch that.
- A loser gets waterboarded.
(all laughing)
- I'd love to watch.
I had a massage recently
at hotel and I dunno.
(all laughing)
- Quite a segue.
- There is a saying it's a segue, right.
And. (chuckling)
(all laughing)
It was my birthday early this year,
and I went for a massage.
You said, waterboarded, right?
They put a tea towel over my face.
They put a tea towel in my
face, then covered me in tea.
(all laughing)
And it was like, "This is
waterboarding, isn't it?"
- The numbers, what do they mean, Chris?
- There's this towel on my face,
and it was liquid pouring down.
(Chris murmuring)
(Connor and Joey laughs)
And then she was like. (speaking Japanese)
I'm like. (murmuring)
(Joey laughs)
(Chris murmuring)
- The room number.
What's the room number?
(all laughing)
- It's horrific.
- My God.
- Just be careful you
get a massage in Japan.
- Jesus.
- What kind of massage
was this?
- Oh God, I-
- It was a tea massage.
- [Garnt] Tea massage.
- Tea massage.
- They cover you in blankets
then just poor tea over you.
(Joey laughs)
And I was like, "Oh, therapy innit?"
- Turn into a teabag.
- It was fucking awful.
- I had the most awkward
massage experience ever.
I went and I just wanted to go too,
and it was included in
the hotel and I thought,
"Oh, why not?
I've never gone for massage before.
Why not?
What could go wrong?"
So, I'm face down on this massage table,
it's already quite awkward.
She's really sheepish about everything,
and struggling to explain to me
to take off my shirt and whatnot.
I'm like, "Oh, okay, yeah, I got it."
I lie down and I'm like chilling.
And then I hear she's just
preparing oils and stuff.
And then just smashing,
like glass breaking.
- What?
- And then I'm awkwardly
like, "What's going on?"
And then she's trying to
stealthily pick up this glass
as if she hadn't broke it.
Like I hadn't realized.
- Oh my God, crap.
- And I could just hear
her every now and then,
I could just hear a
little. (tongue clicking)
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
I'm just like, "It's okay,
just get the fucking broom,
it's already too late."
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- I thought you were gonna
say you got a glass massage,
or something.
- [Garnt] I was like-
- Shatters a bottle over your head.
- It doesn't seem outside
the realms of possibility
given what I've experienced.
- It was so awkward.
Just 40 minutes of this
poor woman trying to pick up
this glass.
(Joey laughs)
And I'm like, "Just go at it,
I don't give a shit.
The ambiance is already ruined."
- Do you want a massage in Japan, Garnt?
- I am not a fan of massages at all,
but that's because I'm
used to Thai massages where
it's like they just
beat the shit outta you.
- Yeah, not a fan.
That was my first time,
and I don't think I want another one.
- Yeah.
- I don't mind massages,
but I'm usually not that stiff.
(Chris laughs)
So I don't really
need a massage.
(Garnt laughs)
- Well, okay.
(all laughing)
- You know, we're trying to talk it out.
Maybe I do need a massage then.
(all laughing)
I need a different kinda massage.
- Oh good, God.
- The Anime Man.
- When you get your haircut here,
sometimes they just start massaging you,
it's really fucking weird.
I'm like, "It's okay,
I didn't pay for that."
- 'Cause I'm like tend
in my head, I laugh.
They're like, I'm like. (chuckling)
(all laughing)
I'm like. (chuckling)
- What?
- And the guy's like. (speak Japanese)
'Cause I'm like tend in my head.
I dunno, it's weird,
I laugh at that when they
massage me in the head.
- Japanese services are beyond extra.
You do need a massage where
you're getting your haircut.
It's just-
- The weirdest ones is when
they're shampooing you,
and then they start massaging your head.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] You ever got those?
- I love that.
- I like that.
- Natsuki did that to me once,
I just felt really uncomfortable.
(all laughing)
'Cause Natsuki has a beauty salon, right,
and I was like, "Natsuki,
this is a bit weird."
And he's like, "Don't think that."
(Chris grunts)
- 'Cause you don't see
him as the kind of guy
that's stroking your head.
(all laughing)
- No.
- He's good at it though.
- He's good at it.
- He's good at stroking one's head.
(all laughing)
- I think the weirdest
place I got a massage,
'cause I was staying in this
high class hotel in Thailand.
And of course they
wanna make it seem like,
they have service people everywhere,
so of course,
in some hotels they have
people in the toilet
to hand out towels, right.
- (chuckling) Oh no.
- Hand out towels and just freshen up,
if you need to freshen up.
So I'm going to this
toilet and the guy asked me
if I want a towel.
And I say, "No, no, it's okay."
So I go up and go to the urinal,
and I hear some footsteps.
I was like, "What's going on?
Is there someone else about?"
And then I feel two hands on my shoulder.
(Connor and Chris chuckles)
Mid-stream,
as I'm pissing. (laughing)
(all laughing)
And I'm just like.
And it's just the most awkward
piss I've had in my life.
- Oh my God.
- At this point,
it's just like I'm
struggling to get it out now.
- Stage fright.
- Because I have someone
massaging my shoulders.
'Cause I'm trying to piss
in this urinal, right.
- Man, you must have saw
how stiff you. (chuckling)
(all laughing)
- Oh, you're a bit stiff there, buddy.
(Garnt laughing)
- And so we finish and I go up to the sink
to wash my hands and I look
at him and he's expecting
a tip from the-
- Oh my God.
- Which one?
- Huh?
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
- I think you already gave him a tip.
- It's probably the most awkward tip
I've given in my life.
- That's awful.
- 'Cause I'm just like,
"I really don't want
to give you this tip."
- I can just imagine you
just slowly turning around,
and just the Jojo behind the shoulder.
(Garnt laughs)
- That's horrific.
I think I'd rather have
water boarding with tea.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
than have urinal, piss massage.
(Garnt laughing)
That awful.
- That must be on the top
10 list of places you don't
want to be massaged in.
(Garnt laughing)
Pissing in a urinal.
That's gotta be up there,
that's gotta be up there.
- Abandoned shipyard.
- I already don't like
it when people talk to me
when I'm standing in front of a urinal,
let alone getting massaged.
(Garnt laughs)
Christ.
- Wow.
- Any other places you've
been massaged, Chris?
- I think that's it, yeah.
Let's never speak of massages again.
(Joey laughs)
- By the way, congrats on
getting verified by the way.
I don't think you were verified last time.
(hands clapping)
- Oh that's beyond getting a
studio, beyond Ken Watanabe.
- No, no, no, you got Twitter verified,
you got Twitter verified.
- That was a real gold star. (chuckling)
- You got verified before Trash Taste.
- Yes.
- Yeah, so you technically won the bet.
- It turned I'd been inputting
it wrong the entire time.
- [Garnt] I fucking knew it.
- You're supposed to be
like, "Are you an influencer?
Yes, blah blah, Abroad in Japan."
- How are you applying?
- I was like,
"Film director, yeah."
(all laughing)
- Was like, "Are you Quentin Tarantino?
Yeah."
And I've been doing it wrong,
and I did it right the one time,
it was done in one minute.
- (laughing) Film director.
- You're in.
- [Joey] Film director.
- Got a bit too big for my boots.
It wasn't very affable.
- Did they ask you like
something on IMDB or something?
How did they define that?
- It was something like that, yeah,
and I was just doing it right.
So I made Natsuki the movie.
(all laughing)
That's a movie?
- Have you heard of Wacky weekends?
That's on the same level as Spielberg.
(Chris and Joey chuckling)
- But you know, I've doing it wrong.
So I was glad, I was happy.
- What was the highlight
of your year, Chris?
- Oh fuck, I don't know.
There's lots of cool things.
Oh, too much volcano.
Yeah.
- Oh yeah.
We talked about that last time as well.
- Top 14, I choose it, probably that.
And then-
- Why'd you say top 14?
Just say it was fourteenth, Chris.
- [Chris] Top 14.
- [Joey] Top 14?
- Just say top 50 then.
- How much did it make?
It made a whopping.
How much do you think it made?
(Joey chuckles)
- Top 14, $20,000.
- No.
- I'll tell you, I tell
you how much it made.
- I already know.
- $15,000.
- It made $2,000. (chuckling)
We split it three ways.
- Let's go music industry hype.
- And that's-
- A top 14 iTune song mix.
- It was like two and a half thousand.
- No wonder you came onto title A.
(Chris laughs)
- Is that how you found the
budget to build your new studio?
- That is it, the money went towards that.
(Garnt laughs)
- He said he would split it,
but we never saw the money.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- I gave you a trip Hokkaido.
(Garnt laughs)
- He invited me to the studio,
he was like, "Here's the law,
too much volcano money
right here, thank you."
- Well, I mean, yeah,
it's been a good year.
The studio's good and
the Ken Watanabe thing,
they're supposed to get a
Ken Watanabe documentary
out in December,
but it's just really hard to edit it.
I'm really embarrassed watching it back,
'cause I-
- Why?
- I completely crumbled as an interviewer.
I was gonna try and speak Japanese to him.
And then my mind just went when I,
'cause it's just weird,
you're sitting here, it's Ken Watanabe,
he's got a coffee, I've got a coffee.
I'm like, "So then Ken, oh God."
And also, I didn't sleep
the night before I met him,
I didn't sleep at all.
- 'Cause you were nervous?
- Yeah, I was fucking nervous.
- Well, yeah, I don't blame you.
- I was like, "Ken Watanabe."
- I think anyone would be.
- I was nervous as hell
and I didn't sleep at all.
And so I was like, "Ken." (mumbling)
Just rubbish.
(Joey laughs)
My performance,
I wasn't happy with it.
- Would you say you were starstruck?
- A little bit but not,
he's just a normal guy.
He was in Last Samurai and Inception.
- (laughing) Just a normal
dude, Last Samurai, yeah.
- He's a normal guy and also
like the best actor in Japan,
but a normal guy.
(Joey laughs)
But it was just weird,
it's just so trippy,
I was just sitting
there with Ken Watanabe,
it was really weird.
- I just like how you just
called him a normal guy
in Last Samurai.
- He's not a normal guy, he's-
- It's that other normal guy, Tom.
- The only Oscar nominated Japanese actor.
- That Tom guy's a pretty
normal guy as well.
- Yeah that was Tom,
but he's a nice bloke, nice bloke.
- I mean, I don't blame you.
I think anyone will be fucking starstruck.
- Think he spoiled
Inception for me though.
Told me-
- [Connor] You told me about this.
- He was like-
- You haven't seen Inception?
- Yeah, I've seen it.
You know, there's a spinner
that keeps on going.
- Oh yeah.
- It's up for interpretation, the endings.
- And he's like, "Oh, it
just keeps on spinning
after he's in the dream world."
I was like, "Ken, you've just
ruined Inception for me."
- Oh no, he's in the real world.
Michael Caine actually ruined it, I think.
Because I believe that-
- Ken said he was in the fake world.
(Garnt laughs)
And he was like, "It was
in the script but it was-"
- What's real?
- It was in the script or something.
- No,
I think they actually broke it down.
I think Leonardo DiCaprio
wears a ring or something
in the real world.
Or that's how you distinguished
between dream world,
and the real world.
I think he wears a ring
or there's a piece of item
on him that makes it
distinguished between real world,
and the dream world.
And in the last scene
he is in the real world.
- Would it be a large stretch
to say that both Michael Caine,
and Ken Watanabe may
possibly be speculating.
- It's possible.
Ken was pretty adamant.
- We have different spoilers
for everyone.
- Adamant.
- Yeah, yeah.
Maybe they're playing to be like,
"I'll say it's real, you say it's fake."
- As much as that is compelling.
I think if he said it's in
the script, he said that,
I'm pretty inclined to-
- I don't think it was in the script.
I think Nolan told them individually.
So maybe he just told
them different things.
- What I did know-
- Yeah, maybe.
He was like, "It's real,
no, it's actually not."
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- In the documentary I did at the end,
I had this scene where I'm like,
"Ken, I wanna have a spinner
and pretend like I dunno,
if I'm in the real world or not,
'cause I'm interviewing
Kim Watanabe or something."
And apparently he was like, "Yeah, sure."
He's really good at the spinner.
And he said in Inception,
every time they needed a spinner,
he would just come out and
be the one that did it,
'cause he was like the
best at spinning it.
So it's a little fact about Ken Watanabe.
- He's great at spinning.
(Chris chuckles)
- [Connor] Spinning man.
- You've been in the Last
Samurai, spinning guy.
- Normal spinning man in Last Samurai.
- That's what makes him normal, right?
- He can spin shit.
- I was intimidated until
he got his spinner out,
and started spinning it.
- Like, "Oh, well, thank
God, he's just a normal guy."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Crumble in front of the spinner.
- It was bad.
- I guess, 'cause in Japanese culture,
they have the koma.
- They do yeah.
- It's like the spinners.
- [Connor] I think you're very
harsh on yourself as well.
- I am pretty harsh on myself.
- [Connor] Yeah, you-
- It's quite a serious documentary, yeah.
Hasn't come out yet but-
- I need to see it for myself
if it's actually crumbly Chris,
or if it's just you
being harsh on yourself.
- Well, I'm gonna use
CGI to make me look good.
(Joey laughs)
And be the best.
- We need a-
- We need a Chris AI.
- Need a Chris AI.
- Voice synthesizer.
- "Well, hello there,
Ken, how are you doing?"
And have like some weird
synthesized version of me.
- Just autotune yourself.
- I'm still editing it
to make me look good and not shit.
- Did you film that-
- That's what we normally
do in editing.
- You filmed that like a
couple months ago, right?
- I filmed it October, in November.
- Yeah.
- I met him twice, yeah.
- How long is it gonna be?
- 25 Minutes maybe.
Yeah.
- And it might be out by the
time this episode's out, maybe.
- Yeah.
- Maybe, maybe. (chuckling)
It was good,
I went for dinner with him,
and lots of people and this man
at this restaurant just came up to him,
and Ken,
the whole premise of the documentary,
he's worked to help sort
of recover this town
called Kesennuma that got
destroyed by the tsunami.
And he's got a cafe there,
and he's done a lot of great stuff for it,
but we're just out for dinner and this man
just comes up and he's like, "Oh Ken-San."
(Chris speaks Japanese)
Thank you for the. (chuckling)
I dunno why but it's funny.
He's like, "Thank you for the trumpets."
(all laughing)
It turned out Ken had
really generously donated
like a thousand trumpets to the town.
- A thousand?
There's probably more
kids that are in the town.
It's not a thousand.
- It might be.
- Why trumpets?
- 'Cause he plays the trumpet.
And he was like, "Get everyone a trumpet."
So this man just coming to say-
- "I like trumpets."
- And he's like-
- [Connor] I feel like you've
misremembered this story.
- No, "He's like, Ken, thank you."
- Get yourself a trumpet, everyone.
Everyone get yourself a trumpet."
- Why?
Because I like trumpets.
- "Thank you for the trumpet,
thank you for the trumpets, Ken."
And he's like, "Don't
worry about the trumpets."
What are you gonna do
for the people of Wales?
- I just this-
- Get 'em all in Gwent.
- I just have this image of Ken Watanabe
going to this village,
which has decimated by
a tsunami. (chuckling)
And he just goes,
"You know what you need?
Here's a thousand trumpets."
- [Joey] "You need a trumpet."
- To help the restoration
efforts, you know.
- But he's done an incredible
job there, to be fair.
- [Connor] I'm excited to-
- And I think that was really nice.
A lot of celebrities,
they get involved just
for the sake of it for PR,
but he's actually
befriended everyone there.
And it's a really powerful story.
- Man in Last Samurai, top
spinner, trumpet dealer.
What isn't he?
- When are you donating-
- [Chris] Yeah,
what are we doing for Wales?
- A thousand shitty cosplays
to your village.
- What would you donate
to the people.
The people of Anglesea.
- Sausage rolls for everyone.
(Garnt laughs)
- A thousand sausage rolls.
- A million sausage rolls.
- [Chris] "Thank you for
the sausage rolls, Connor."
(all laughing)
- They'll come to me and be like,
"Thank you, Connor, for
feeding my children."
In front of Chris.
I'll pay someone to come up and do it.
When I'm in Wales, I'll organize it.
I'll have someone to come up-
- Just get the entire town to be in it.
- Keep coming up to me and be like,
"Thank you, Connor, thank you".
And Chris will be like, "What's up?"
I'll be like, "Don't worry about it."
- What would you donate, Chris?
- What I donate?
- Yeah.
- Nothing but chicken, probably.
(Garnt laughs)
Bucket of chicken.
- That's probably why
there's a shortage right now.
- Chicken buckets for everyone.
- Cholesterol of Ken's is
gonna go through the roof.
(Garnt and Chris laughing)
- Yeah that's it.
- I gotta piss.
- All right.
(scene whooshes)
- This episode is sponsored by Bokksu.
- Do you know what time of view it is?
It's time for some loving.
Valentine's day is upon us.
And do you know what will
please your beloved partner,
this Valentine?
- My undivided attention and
maybe a box of chocolates.
- No, I'm so offended
that you would even insist
that it's not Bokksu because it is Bokksu.
- [Joey] Bokksu makes such
a perfect and memorable gift
for anyone in your life who
appreciates Japanese snacks,
and culture.
Especially during a time where
people aren't able to travel
as easily as they would like,
because this season we've
got a couple of sweet,
and delicious treats for you to try out.
- [Garnt] Make your beloved
ones as happy as a plum
this Valentine's day with these
homemade Ummi Sake candies.
This candy is flavored with plum sake
for an elegant sweet treat.
- Next we have the
Tsukisamu Anpan chocolate.
(Joey gasps)
Here's a fun fact, gentlemen.
Anpan is a sweet roll that's
filled with bean paste.
This Anpan gets an
upgrade with the addition
of rich chocolate.
- Oh you'll be Jonesing.
And lastly, we have these
Hokohoko purple yams.
This purplelicious pastry is called Manju,
and the bun is made with pie crust,
and the filling gets an extra
dose of flavor and color
from these mildly sweet purple yams.
- That's what I'm talking about.
- Get all these lovely treats with Bokksu,
and use our code Trash Taste 10,
and the link in the description
to get 10% off your subscription.
What are you waiting for?
Get yourself and your special
loved one, a Bokksu box,
this Valentine's day.
- Back to the show.
(scene whooshes)
- While Joey was away for a piss,
Chris revealed that he also
doesn't know the difference
between a trumpet or a trombone.
- I mean, I know difference.
I just can't remember if it
was a trumpet or trombone.
- 'Cause Ken could have donated trombones.
- [Joey] A thousand. (chuckling)
- To the village and Chris
can't actually remember.
- You'd have to watch the documentary,
out and Abroad Japan to find
the mystery will be solved.
- How do you not know the difference?
- I just can't remember what it was.
- The long one is a trombone.
- Yeah, we all know that.
- Garnt doesn't know that.
- We all know the trombone, trumpet.
(Joey laughs)
- We all know the difference.
- Affable, affable.
- Affable.
- When all fails, just say you're affable.
- Just say affable, affable.
- Did you get a free
subscription to the Japan times
with your article?
- No.
- How you gonna read it?
(all laughing)
- That's the problem innit?
You can read the article,
you have to just sign up, it's free.
- I tried reading it and I was like,
"I'm not signing up-"
- You're the worst.
Don't want you reading it.
Don't you read my article.
- I wanna hear about this
so-called affable man
I've yet to meet.
- The affable Chris
mused as he leaned back
on his Ramenen shop.
(Joey and Chris laughs)
- So affable.
- [Garnt] Oh my fucking God.
- But it's been a good year, innit it?
- Yeah.
What I wanna know is why do
you feel like you had to one up
our studio and build your own, Chris?
- I'll admit when I came here, I was like,
"I want a space now."
I've always wanted a space where I can-
- This is what made you do it.
- Yeah, I was like,
"I've gotta one up those bastards."
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
"There might be three of
them in a team of 48 people,
but I'm gonna one up them by myself,
in a room with a massively
expensive set, brilliant."
- I think you did one up us though,
to be fair.
- You definitely did.
- Pewdiepie called me a son of a bitch,
'cause he was jealous.
(announcer laughs)
Someone sent me a clip
and Pewdiepie's like,
"Motherfucking Abroad in Japan,
the studio is growing."
I was pretty happy about that.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
I was pretty smug about that,
I was quite happy.
No, certainly when I came here I was like,
"I don't know why I
haven't got a space yet."
I've always put
unnecessary shit on myself.
(all laughing)
Not literally, shut up.
I-
(Connor laughs)
- I hate sitting across from him,
'cause his eye line's
always fucking there,
but-
- He's always finding a weak spot.
- But I edited all Abroad in Japan videos
by myself on a MacBook up until last year.
- What?
- I didn't use a desktop
with a screen.
- That sounds horrible.
- I literally torture
myself doing Abroad.
- Yeah, why would you do that?
- Do you even have two screens?
- No, it's the MacBook.
So I only got an iMac like
last year and a proper screen
to edit on and it's sort of 10 years,
almost 10 years in now.
It makes sense to have a space.
And honestly the most I've used it
for is just having meetings with people,
and people come over.
It's better than just like,
"Oh, come on over to my apartment,
watch out for the sock draw,
and the used FamilyMart wrappers.
Watch out."
It's nice to have a space
where I can actually sit,
and just create and do things.
- I guess, to be fair though,
80% of your content is
also outside as well.
So.
- But that was because I
had no space to film it.
Abroad in Japan was born
just me in an apartment
complaining about how
much I hate going outside.
- We had the 12 days of Christmas.
- Christmas, clever, innit?
(Garnt snickering)
- Done well.
- What are you snickering
at my clever title?
- So clever.
- Really clever.
- Really clever that you came up
that there was the word
Chris in Christmas.
- Christmas, genius.
- He's like, "I finally figured it out."
- Only I could have
thought that up but yeah,
it's just cool to have a space to create,
and have somewhere like that Ramenen shop,
that's just sort of,
bit of my imagination for years to have
that sort of imaginary things,
imaginary set translated to real life.
This kind of crazy thing.
And I've had some actual serious
film companies message me
about doing something in there.
- Oh sick.
- From Hollywood, like,
"We wanna film some stuff in there."
- Oh wow.
- [Garnt] Shit, okay.
- So it'll be interesting to
see what happens going forward.
- How long did that take to make?
What was the entire process around that?
- So the guy came in and I was like,
"I want a Ramenen shop
there and a street there."
And he went, "Oh."
He got a tape measure, pulled out an iPad,
just went. (lips swooshing)
And just was like, "This?"
I was like. (fingers click)
That's it.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
But the man knew what he was
doing, he was really good.
It was a company called GuNi, I think.
And they built sets for
Alice in Borderland,
and a pair of Netflix shows.
- [Garnt] How'd you find them?
- Just through a friend.
He knew them, he worked with them.
And then they went away,
a design, they sent me the CGI,
what it looked like.
And I was like,
"Do that, yeah, that, go."
And then they built it,
took about three weeks to
build it in a warehouse
in Shiba where they
built Disneyland rides.
- Oh wow.
- They sent me footage
of men crafting lights,
and woodwork and neon lights and shit.
And I was like,
"Wow, this is pretty intense."
And then took three days
to build it in the studio.
And I wasn't there that time.
I think I was on Wacky
weekend with you or something
when I was doing it.
And I came back to Sendai
and I met the team,
and they were all just dead.
(Joey laughs)
They hated me.
'Cause usually they build
sets for film and TV.
And my (chuckling) studio
is in a decrepit building
from the sixties.
It's filled with asbestos.
There's cracks over the wall,
the building's coming down.
And they're shifting
this equipment through
an elevator and stuff
and they looked dead.
And I was like,
"Well done, everyone."
They were like, "Yeah,
get me out of here."
But yeah, wasn't cheap, obviously.
But it's kind of like a,
I mean a lot of people sort of ask me,
"How much did it cost?"
How much did it cost?"
But I don't want to say.
(Garnt laughs)
'Cause everyone,
that will be the thing
everyone thinks of, right.
Always be consumed by that.
And yeah, it's expensive.
But I could have spent that-
- Hire professionals who do it for Disney,
it's best of the best, right?
Of course it looks like it.
- It shows, yeah.
- It definitely shows.
- I'll say it was in
the tens of thousands.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- Pretty obvious.
- Yeah, of course.
- Surely the amount of
electronics in that place is.
- Yeah ,the electronics alone
were almost half the cost,
I think.
The most expensive thing was the crafting,
the woodwork and everything.
- Well, yeah, they got the counter built.
'Cause I remember I saw the space
before you had it in there.
I thought you were
telling me there's gonna
be this set here.
I was like, "No, can't be."
- That's why you were so
shock when you saw it, right?
- I was like, yeah.
I was like, "You're taking the piss,
you can't fit a set in here,
it's like a fucking bedroom."
You can't put anything in there.
- They did a great job with the space.
- They really like-
- It's insane how much
they utilized the space.
- They knew exactly what they were doing,
I'll say that much.
- And yeah, it's a good
investment in myself
for Abroad in Japan and yeah.
- 'Cause you've been doing more content
on your second channel.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's Christmas.
- Yeah, it's Christmas,
it was definitely worth it.
(all chuckling)
- Chris, I remember when you
told me about that early on,
you were like, "I'm gonna
upload daily for 12 days."
I was like, "Good luck with that."
- I almost got there, almost got there.
- How was it doing the
consistent content back to back?
- It reminded me why I
don't do consistent content.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- [Connor] Yeah, you
don't have time to think.
Do you?
- You don't.
I got a comment that really annoyed me.
I don't get triggered that often.
- No, I got a comment.
- Yes you do.
- [Chris] Yeah sure.
(all laughing)
'Cause I've been putting all
these 12 days of Christmas
on my second channel 'cause-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Hello, everyone's got
a second channel now.
It's cool innit?
And (chuckling) the race is on.
Who's now the biggest second channel?
But someone's like, "He's
just rehashing old videos."
'Cause I think I did a video with you.
We just talked about
things that we don't like
about Japan and-
- [Connor] It was the overrated things.
- Yeah,
and I did a deal realtro
about how we nearly died,
and just sitting down having a chat.
And I was like, "Come on, mate."
- Just casual content.
- Spent the entire
fucking year on horseback,
or a plane or a train or a
ferry doing these videos.
Can I just sit in a room
and talk about something
for five minutes?
Let me just chill,
let me just sit in a room.
So.
- That's the point of the second channel.
- Yeah, that's the whole
point of a second channel.
- We have a second channel.
- Exactly.
- Technically our third channel,
'cause I guess Trash
Taste's our second channel.
- There was like a really cute tweet,
that was from a verified account,
and I was tagged to it for some reason.
And they were like,
"Chris, for some reason,
I can't seem to find these
videos on your channel."
(Chris laughs)
And they didn't realize that
he had a second channel.
And I was just like, "Oh, that's so cute."
(all chuckling)
I don't know why.
- And then I closed Twitter. (laughing)
- I was like, "That's cute."
- Told them nothing.
- That's the only wholesome
thing I've ever read on Twitter.
(Joey laughs)
- It was wholesome.
I was like, "I just thought
Chris was in one place."
- But it's nice to have second channel,
as I'm sure you guys have found.
It's nice to just chill out.
'Cause the pressure
you can put yourself on
with the first channel is-
- Yeah.
- Sometimes you just
have an idea for content,
and you're like,
"I can't put this on my first channel."
- Sure, yeah.
- Yeah, exactly.
This is way-
- Monkey tier list, isn't it?
- No, that's main channel content,
like Joey going through
his health card score.
- Yeah, I went through
my health card score
on my second channel.
- Why'd you do that?
- But bro,
come on and say a break,
it would be like,
"Yeah, so everything's great,
cholesterol's dreadful."
- That's basically what I say. (laughing)
- Yeah, I mean,
I got basically A's
and Be's in everything.
And then urine came up
and I got a C, three.
And I was just like,
"How do I fuck up in Europe?"
- [Joey] How do I control my piss?
- Obviously, I'm not being massaged enough
while I'm urinating,
'cause something's going
on with the process, man.
- Did you have bad blood last year?
Has it gone up to A now?
- It's a B now.
- Oh, okay.
- But what's wrong with your urine?
What you do?
- I have no idea.
- It's like acidic, I guess.
- Drinking too much wine.
(Garnt laughs)
- Too much green tea actually.
- What was your results, Chris?
- I haven't done a test.
(Connor and Garnt laughs)
- Let's get your results, Chris.
- I really need to get it.
- Starting poking fun
at who's cholesterol-
- Yeah, exactly.
- Have a look at-
- We all know, I'm gonna win.
- Yeah.
- "I'm gonna win." (laughing)
- I'm gonna have
the best score.
(Garnt laughs)
- It's like golf, bro,
it's like golf, Chris.
You want a lower score.
- I don't really wanna test.
(Connor laughs)
- Not enough high cholesterol
if you don't test it.
- If I don't know.
- When I was a teacher,
the first three years
they'd do it every year.
Right?
After my second year it was really bad,
'cause I'd smoked a lot and
I drank a lot, the time.
The doctor fell off his seat when he saw.
(Connor and announcer laughing)
Makes your cholesterol look healthy.
(Connor laughs)
He was like, "Whoa."
And then gone and fell off the chair
like Humpty fucking Dumpty.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
(chuckling) It was awful.
And I had to spend the next
year just eating a leaf
with chicken.
- [Garnt] (chuckling)
He's taking one leaf.
- (laughing) One leaf.
- Got like a lady bug
slowly working through it.
- But it works, it works.
Yeah, oatmeal and despair.
(Joey laughs)
But no, no,
my cholesterol now must be horrific.
(Connor laughs)
I'm worried about it.
- (chuckling) Why am I laughing?
(Connor laughs)
- [Chris] Laughing at my imminent demise.
- I understand 'cause I
have a similar situation.
- You gonna get tested then?
Or are you just gonna put that off?
- Too busy?
- I don't really know how
to get tested.
I don't have a big company backing me.
Do I just walk in and be
put something in my arm?
"Go, it's done."
- I think you just go into,
yeah, you can just book it.
You can get a full
standard health checkup.
- We can make a content out of that.
That's a-
- That's a second channel,
that's a second channel video right there.
- That's a narrative right there.
- "Rehashing old content."
(Garnt laughs)
Did you do the thing where
you have to drink barium,
and they have the
radioactive liquid thing?
- No.
- I think that's if you
have stomach issues,
or when you're older,
I think they do that.
But at probably, what is it?
At 40 if you get a colonoscopy.
(Chris wails)
Have to get a colonoscopy.
A poor business, man.
- Yeah.
- I had the one, endoscopy.
I was worse than the
hotel room we stayed in.
And that was the worst thing
I've ever had, endoscopy.
- Were you awake for that?
- Yeah.
- Oh God.
- I went to the worst doctor
ever and I thought it would
be like a little thin
piece of string, right.
(Joey laughs)
And it's a cable like that thing.
- Oh.
- And he's like, "This
will numb your throat."
It didn't.
(Joey laughs)
And I was like. (wailing)
This doctor was really bad,
so bad that it's closed now.
(Joey laughs)
I think it must have failed
the health exam.
- Oh my God.
Sendai, somewhere.
They did the endoscopy,
they did like a broom cupboard.
- [Connor] No.
- And I was next to the room
where everyone's waiting,
and I was like. (hurling)
Just gagging for about
25 minutes over and over.
- You sure you went to a doctor?
- Well.
- Might have just been
some dude's house.
- It got fucking closed down.
'Cause I don't think it passed the test.
- Just some dude in a lab coat.
- And worst of all,
they had a screen in front of me,
like a 42 inch plasma screen of my here.
(Joey laughs)
- No, oh my God.
- And I didn't look at it once.
'Cause I was like, "No, no, no."
He was like, "Look, look, you're fraught."
And I was like, "Fuck off."
(all laughing)
And then they printed it
out and they pulled it out,
and it's just, oh God, it's horrible.
You have to wear a mouthpiece
and they feed it through.
It's like torture.
It's up there with tea, water boarding.
(Joey chuckles)
But like-
- Sounds like a scene
out of Saw or something.
You just wake up,
you just got the mouse piece on.
- That's honestly in my mind.
- You have to escape the endoscopy.
(Garnt laughs)
- The worst bit, the
worst bit you called out.
And.
- I feel sick hearing.
- There was a poster to
print out five photos
and after 2:30 I ran out paper
and the images were not stored anywhere.
So they lost and I saw the guy exasperated
and like the nurse they're like,
and he looked at me
like, we ran out of pitch
and I was like.
- Is this is how he spoke?
- He spoke in English.
Oh right. And like he
sort of insinuated that
we should probably do it again.
- Oh my God.
- And I like, no, no we're good.
We're fine. Don't worry.
No cancer. We're good.
And like, fucking know, Jesus.
- What did you just shut him for.
- I got really bad, like stomach acids,
like three.
Well, I discovered it basically.
I was really stressed for
a long period of time.
- Okay.
- Really bad stomach acid
and the stomach ulcer.
I think this was off. This
was, I dunno when this was,
I think this was stuff I'd started
are going YouTube full time.
Do YouTube. Yeah. It's great.
And I was really stressed and burnt out
and some of my stomachs
just acid it around.
- Yeah.
- So they did that and yeah fuck it was,
it was probably like the
top three worst experience
ever got a really bad.
- COVID test done. Not one place.
And I was like, great,
what are we doing it?
They were like, "Oh, just come here.
Follow us."
Just like the emergency stairway.
Like outside the fire escape.
You did the same thing.
- Oh, that place the year.
- They did in the fire escape.
- Yeah.
- What? And then he was like,
all right, open your mouth.
And I'm like, "Oh, so I was like,
why are we doing it outside?"
He's like, "Oh, 'cause
it's ventilated the office.
Isn't ventilated.
'Cause if you have COVID we don't get it.
And I'm like, "Feel
like it could have been
a better solution to this
just out in like overlooking."
Like Rappongi just watching
like everyone walk by while
I'm getting something shoved
down my throat. God's.
- Awful.
- Jesus.
As for the place we went to
before flying out to England.
Right?
- Yeah.
It's weird.
- But that experience is why I'm like,
"Oh, I don't think I
need the doctor again."
- I've heard really good and
just really bad about Japan.
I felt like," Oh yeah it's alright."
- I think endoscopy is the worst thing
you could do in Japan.
- Sounds like.
- I'm sure you, the topic
con what have you done
that's bad.
- The ear thing is pretty bad.
- Oh fuck.
- Well the ear cleaning search.
- You'll do it for fun. It's horrible.
- How is horrible.
- 'Cause you know, I don't clean my ears.
- You don't?
- No.
- That's gross. It's awful
- No, most doctors recommend not to put
anything in your ear.
- Oh really?
- Nothing should ever
be going in your ear.
- If you're watering it and.
- If you're watering, it would come out.
You get a smack shooting,
put cotton buds in your ear.
Even on the package top.
- Oh the cotton buds say,
they say cotton buds are the worst.
- Yeah. Cotton buds are the worst.
Like do ears not get itchy?
- No.
- I get my ears get itchy.
Why?
- My ears get really itchy.
- They get itchy is.
- No. So you know,
this guy goes in and starts scraping
the fucking ear drums and stuff.
He goes so deep.
- Yeah.
- But people love it on YouTube.
For some reason. It's like people
absolutely love the videos.
- It's like people popping videos.
- Yeah.
- It's that same genre.
- I helped Charla film her video.
'Cause she did it once I
think made loads of views
and she's like, "Everyone loves this.
I'm gonna do it again."
- Yeah.
- Wanna film it? I was like, yeah, sure.
I went along and you get like a live feed.
- Yeah. It's awful.
- On a big screen.
- He was saying there.
- Always with live feeds on a big screen.
- Inch plasma screen TV.
And you the optimal angle
that you can't look away.
- It's like watching June,
it was so I was like nearly gagging
while watch I had to like look away.
- Dude, I had to stop him
at one point and be like,
I gotta go and I need to
go and sit on the toilet.
I was just like, I was like
lying on this toilet bowl.
Just like, (groaning) nd then.
- Was that from him going into your ear
or from the footage?
- Both.
Both. So like just seeing,
seeing the footage combined with like,
it was really painful.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I don't ever touch my ears.
- Yeah.
- I don't put anything in.
- It's super sensitive.
- it's super sensitive.
- Yeah.
- Obviously people who clean
their rose all the time,
it's not a big deal.
You know, you can do it,
but I haven't done it and
this guy's going ham on me.
He's good at what he does,
boss, man knows how to do it.
Don't get me wrong.
But holy fuck, I was not ready.
And then he was like,
"No, we're not done yet."
When he's got a deep clean.
And then he starts going deeper
and it really feels like
he's like really inside.
Like I would of put
anything even quite close.
- Scratching your eardrum. Right, yeah.
- Really far to a point where
I was genuinely concerned.
And you know, some doctors are like,
"Yeah, it's a load of shit.
This whole air cleaning started, you know,
doesn't do anything and it's dangerous.
'Cause you pop ear crumbs and stuff."
It was yeah, it was genuinely
like I wouldn't do it again.
- Yeah, actually.
- Well, 'cause it wasn't my idea.
It was Canada wanted the, and
I was like, yeah, whatever.
Sure. I mean, it sounds disgusting,
but they didn't find anything.
- Did they find anything?
How much did they clean?
- Oh, like a ship time.
- Did they find anything like.
- A society in his ear?
- It was like after a flooded pass
and the sewage system
has been cleaned out.
It was like the red sea
partying in my ears.
Like it was, you finally see in there,
but I mean, you know, it was not fun.
- 'Cause I actually bought one of
those ear picker things with
the camera at the end of it.
- Yeah.
- And you can.
- Sydney bought one as well.
- Yeah. You can like,
you can connect it on
your phone to see it.
- Yeah. No, I remember.
- 'Cause I clean my ears pretty often.
- What's wrong with people.
- I remember one time, a
few years ago actually now,
so me and Sydney went swimming
once in a pool, right?
- Yeah.
- And so one time
we went swimming and we went out
and she had some water stuck in her ears
and normally you just shake it out.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah. Shake it out.
So this water just would
not get out of her ears.
So it was stuck in there
and I was just like,
"Just lay like that. Just lay like that.
It's fine. It's fine."
- Yeah.
- And it just pass.
And so this water just
what didn't come out.
- I don't know where this is going.
- Yeah. So I stayed in there
for like days to the point
where her ears started hurting
'cause I guessed that.
- It could be an infection.
- Yeah.
It got near infection.
- So you get like an ear infection.
So we actually had to
go to the doctor, right?
So we took her to the doctor
and the doctor tries cleaning
her ears and they can't like,
for some reason they can't
get this liquid out. Right?
- Yeah.
- So.
- It makes me feel
disgusting even hearing this.
- Yeah.
So, what they had to do was they had to,
they put this solution in, right.
This, some kind of solution,
which like softens the ear.
They wax or something like that.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So they put this solution in
and left in for like a
good few minutes, right?
I didn't know what I was expecting because
I didn't know how, I didn't know what
was blocking her canal this bad.
And so they put this,
they put the liquid in,
drain it and then they get like this
mini kind of vacuum kind of thing.
Just like vacuum out,
kind of clean the air.
Right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
All right. So I just remember, right?
I just remember Sydney lying down
and the nurse just like
vacuuming her ear out. Right?
Just waiting for something to come out
and then out plops this
ball of black ear wax.
Like you could hear the
splat on the ground like,
this wasn't ear wax.
This was like a Lovecraftian
nightmare creature man.
- Like the thing.
- Yeah.
It was like the thing, I swear to God,
like I was not expecting that, right?
- Holy shit.
- Not even the nurse was 'cause like this,
this ball just drops out of her ear.
- Yeah.
- And me and a nurse
are just looking at this ball,
like eyes wide open and
nurse just like takes it.
And Cindy's like, whoa,
whoa. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
And she's like, "What's happened,"
but like, I'm just like,
"Cindy, you do not want, see
what just came out your ear."
It was massive. I didn't
know ear wax to get that big.
- 'Cause I've had that before as well.
'Cause I have like really
naturally very tough ear wax.
Like it's like very dry.
- Ear wax, top trumps in air.
- Yeah.
It's like, naturally really, really dry.
- They smell yeast.
- Mine's like naturally really dry.
So if I don't clean it out
consistently then it hardens
and turns into like rock form.
And then that's when you
get like the whole water
stuck in your ear, ear infection.
I feel like I used to get.
- Ear of like, if you start doing it,
it just starts happening.
And then you like.
- I used to get ear infections
all the time as a kid.
'Cause I had just like
rock hard ear infection.
- Yeah. I've never had an
ear infection all of my life.
- I mean once when a
bumblebee went of my ear
and stung in my ear.
- Oh Jesus Christ.
- That triggered an infection.
- Yeah.
- This is horrible.
- How was that?
How to get in there?
- I was like six running
around small field, having fun.
They just went.
- That was the last
time Chris had fun ever.
- After that, the last the laughter died.
- You found a camera. It was all over.
- I can't even do it yourself
fucking ear cleaning.
- Disgusting that.
- Yeah. It's like doing
yourself, colonoscopy.
- It's a thing.
- You're next.
- Do it and up.
- Get it in there.
- 'Cause it's like, apparently it's like
a thing that Japanese couples do.
They clean each other's
ears and stuff. It's.
- You say colonoscopy?
- All right, honey bend over.
- You laugh but there's probably
a couple or two out there that do it.
- Yeah. No, my mom used to clean my ears
all the time when I was little.
- That's probably why you were
getting like ear infectious.
'Cause she started the cycle of cleaning.
- You not supposed to go
in there though? Yeah.
- Yeah. You're not supposed
to put anything in there.
Like it's I dunno why, but
Japan's obsessed of being clean.
So that's probably why.
- I love the Trash Taste podcast.
You learn about the important things.
Ear hygiene, top of the list.
Who needs anime anymore?
- I just put.
- No more animates.
Just ear cleaning.
- Dou you have ear infection going on?
- Huh?
- Do you ever ear infection?
- No.
- I don't know I had one.
- Yeah. I used to get them all the time.
It was horrible.
- Yeah.I mean.
- I feel like the wax is like
a natural barrier of sorts.
- No. It is. It is.
- It's.
- No body.
- I thought it was a natural.
- I mean, it's there for a reason. Right?
Like dust and shit getting in.
But there are sometimes when
there is just a big buildup of
wax and it just gets like, it
really gets itchy sometimes.
- Yeah. Be days.
- I mean yeah. Like doctors have them.
- Maybe I do an Amber.
- You just say one of the toilet.
- Just line up, just get
a bottle, get a bottle.
And just.
- God.
Well we just said about 5G.
Do you see that thing in the knees
recently with the 5G necklace? You this.
- What? No.
- So people that are going
5G, they can get a necklace.
That's supposed to like
stop the waves of 5G
hitting you.
- Can't be serious.
- It turns out this
necklace is radioactive.
It's got a fucking Plutonium in it.
And so the sheer irony that
people are trying to, you know,
get rid of the dangerous 5G
and they wearing this necklace.
- Like be Hulk.
- Yeah.
- Is like caseinogen. And it's like.
- My God.
- Are you off your rockers?
It's quite a new story.
- It's kind like the COVID
necklaces that Japan was selling
one necklace.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah. So, apparently they
were selling these necklaces.
- Viruses be gone.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
- That gave everyone who wore
them like a protective shield.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
On the packaging.
There's like this happy woman
and there's just like this
dome shape, like shield around her.
Like, yes you're free of all the viruses.
- What's in it?
- Oh, I don't know.
- Plutonium.
- Uranium 45, 255. That's.
- Something radioactive.
- I'm bit of few places
where all the staff
are wearing them.
I'm assuming like the companies
like you have to wear these.
- Yeah, yeah.
To serve our customers.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah.
- No. I mean.
- It's like a ship.
- I remember when I went
back home to see my mom,
some of our family members had sent them,
their necklaces as well.
I was like, "Mom, you know,
this is bullshit," right?
You know he can't have a necklace
that just prevents viruses.
That's not how viruses work.
- Yeah. The virus rocks.
I'm like, oh he's got it on.
- Jesus.
- Gotta say the Harry
Potter spell or something.
It's like virus be gone, you know, no.
- Somebody more useful in
the shield than doing though.
At least it can block
anything that old in dun?
- Oh, well I mean to a degree.
- Oh one in June.
- Fucking was paper.
It didn't do anything.
They just turned it on. What?
Just waste energy.
- No, that's why they didn't
have guns in dune, right?
- Yeah.
- That's that's the whole point.
That's the whole law.
That's.
- They still got shot.
They pretty sure someone got exploded.
- There's no guns in there.
- James Bond. No time to die.
- It's time to die.
- It's time die.
- Yeah. What do you think of it? Sorry.
Rabbi, man, like what was the point
of him being in the room?
- Worst villain ever. Really.
So shit.
You're not seen it. You're not a bond man.
You're bond man, gum.
- Gosh, doesn't go to
the cinemas in Japan.
- You don't. I mean, I don't
go to the cinemas in general,
unless there's a film I really,
really, really wanna see.
- Yeah.
- Like psycho pass, like psycho.
- Lazy? Lazy movie?
- You know, if.
- There is psychopath movie.
- If a Kira was in
cinemas, I'd go see a Kira.
- Ah fuck, yeah.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I haven't seen in
cinemas and I think that's,
it's one film that you
would appreciate way more
on the big screen.
- Yeah.
- Like Doom.
- Why didn't you go watch it
in cinemas? I don't understand.
- I just.
- Cinemas for like three months.
- Yeah.
And I dunno, I actually would.
I actually was just like, "Oh,
is this still in cinemas?"
Like last week Googled, it
wasn't so I was like, fuck it.
I guess I'll just watch.
I dunno.
- Just go watch it.
- Sometimes I just get
lazy, you know, because.
- For three months.
- Huh?
Yeah. Yeah.
When's the last time you
watch China make corner.
- Ah, recently.
- Yeah.
- Roken doesn't count.
- Rocken, I watched Rocken.
- That doesn't count.
- Who says?
- That's not doesn't count. That's not.
- When was the last time you watched AADE
that you went paid to watch.
- Arcane.
Jojo, Jojo. Yeah. Jojo.
Arcane, Jojo, and Arcane.
- You know, sometimes
you just have something
that's not on the top
approach, your priority list.
And then you just slips and
then you miss your opportunity
unfortunately.
- Yeah.
I've said a billion times,
but I just like the theater experience,
the right way to enjoy movie.
- I mean the Matrix might
have been a bit me, but the,
you know, in the cinema IMAX,
it was the first time cinema
Matrix movie in a cinema.
'Cause when it came out 1999, I was nine.
- Yeah.
- And so it was pretty cool
watching like a matrix movie,
the way it was supposed
to be sort of saying
the IMAX was incredible.
- What, are you a Marvel guy at all?
- Yeah. I wanna see the new Spiderman.
I absolutely love Spiderman too.
One of my favorites,
probably my favorite comic.
- Which Spiderman too?
- Oh.
- The original one?
- The original one.
- Okay, okay.
- Alfred Melina.
- Yeah.
- The cracker.
What's so much. I watched
dark waters last week.
- What's that?
- Exactly.
- Where'd you find time
to watch all these films?
- Yeah.
- Don't just get an
evening, you should go.
I'll stream afterwards. It's like.
- Are you spiderman?
- When it comes out,
for some reason, Japan,
it comes up like three weeks
after the rest of the world.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
The matrix came out here
like before anywhere else.
'Cause there's like a scene in Japan.
Maybe that's why,
but like every film in
Japan comes out so late.
- It's so annoying.
- It's either too early or too late.
- Yeah. Because by the.
- Too early, too, too
early, can't be too early.
- By the time it comes out,
the spoiler lift is going to
be gone on like online, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause there's a two week spoiler period
where no one's allowed to spoil it.
And by the time that's gone,
the film still hasn't come out in Japan.
So I'm probably gonna
know what happens in it
before I even go see the film.
- Yeah, I haven't read anything about it.
- I know.
- Spiderman luckily.
Don't fucking say anything.
- Give me.
- It's fall inception. What's next?
- Give me, Ken did that, not me.
Give me $50 and I won't
tell you what happened.
- How about you fuck off.
- Black movie. Blackmail.
Spoiler blackmail.
- Spoiler blackmail.
- Yeah. I watch a lot of,
I watch a good amount of the
Western releases in Japan.
Say I don't even like,
look what it's about.
I just go up and just watch it sometimes
to pour rates of success. I'd
say this was a good movie.
Just Mark Ruffo being
like for like two hours.
It's pretty good.
- Sounds amazing.
- What is the film about.
- Mark Ruffo.
- So Mark Ruffo go.
- It's like Mark Ruffo
just like being a Japanese,
but no it's about how like DuPont,
a chemical company just
poisoned everyone in the world.
Basically.
- Sick?
- Yeah.
- Sounds like a run.
- And how like they did
it for like four years
and Mark Ruffo has like
the lawyer that finds out
and like sues thumb and stuff.
- Oh, so it's based off of a true story.
- Yeah. It's like still ongoing as well.
- Oh wow.
- Yeah.
- It film or the.
- Oh the real life case.
- Yeah.
- It's like poisoned, like
everyone in the world.
- Oh wow. What the book?
- Yeah.
Everyone's been poisoned
by this one chemical
that they were dumping.
- Ah.
- Yeah.
It's pretty sketchy there.
Now it's like one of
the UNS like priorities.
It's like ban this chemical.
It's pretty good movie though.
It's pretty good.
- Really?
You're really selling.
- It's a really paranoid
to drink any water.
- Really, so else on. Thank you.
- I dunno.
- It's just nothing a brief
can fix for, right?
- Yeah. Nothing.
An activated charcoal
can fix. No, it's fine.
It's a good movie Mark
Ruffo we he's right?
I think he's not like the
best actor on earth, but.
- He's just kind of okay in every film.
- He's pretty. Yeah he's pretty good.
I don't.
- He's not like he's amazing.
- I've never compelled
by his performances.
- Yeah. I've seen him in.
That's not Marvel collateral, Tom cruise.
- Yeah he's.
- He plays like an underwhelming
detective. He meets a.
- He's really good at playing
like a wimpy character.
- Yeah.
- Which I dunno.
- Mark Ruffo's agent.
He's got a role already.
He's he's too cool that character.
- 'Cause he's kind of like
a pushover it in the film,
but it kind of plays to his
strengths 'cause then he kind of
gets over it and it develops character.
- Character development.
- Yeah.
- Poor old Mark Ruffo he's
watching this in a room in LA.
He's probably like fuck.
- Hey, Hey, he's a billionaire.
Doesn't mean my billionaire
doesn't mean my sympathy.
Yeah. 'Cause the, I noticed
when the movie starts,
it's like a film by Mark
Ruffo a corp or something.
It's like it's his movie company Mark.
- Oh, is it?
- Yeah. So it's his movie.
It's always so funny about that.
I don't know why just having a,
an actor star in their
own film. I'm always like.
- well we gonna get a con kaon movie.
- What? What's it gonna be about what?
Me doing a crane game two hours.
- Uncut.
- The quest for curious George.
- Yeah. The director's cut.
- Thought I would I make a film with that?
I have no interest in
making a film on, though.
- If I gave you a hundred
million, what would you make?
- More crane game in the air.
- The biggest crane game.
- I spent a hundred thousand dollars.
- I make the shittest squid
game possible for 3 million.
- What constitutes Mr. Beast man.
- $3 million, just like money laundering,
$3 million. Just like a cardboard set.
I would've been actually, in
some ways I think I would.
That would've been almost
as funny were anyway.
Just cardboard version of squid game.
- Yeah. Someone must have done that.
- Probably. Did you see those,
that one hamster channel?
They got like a lot of shit.
- Oh yeah, yeah. Yeah.
- Like made squid game. The
hamster hamster, squid game,
like making these hamsters
drop from like massives.
- Oh my God.
- And there was like spikes and stuff.
- Jesus.
- It was awful.
- I watched the video and it was like,
it's honestly not that bad. Like.
- I dunno, there was some bits
where I was like, yeah, that,
that hamster could have been impaled.
- But if, what if the
hamsters were just CGD in?
- Yeah.
- What if the AI.
- Cancer AI.
- Unfortunately one of
them was voiced by gum
and C your equivalent.
- Unfortunately I think
there's one thing that
you cannot even remotely
try and get away with.
And that is anything with you.
It comes close to abusing animals.
- Yeah.
- It's like the one thing that
you just can't get away with.
- I mean, right, for a so.
- Yeah.
- I think that's that hamster
video was just a bit oof,
but yes.
- Yeah. There'll definitely
better ways to do what I feel.
- Yeah.
- But it's a bit, it's a shame as well.
'Cause that channel, like I've been,
'cause that channel comes with
my recommended all the time.
'cause he like makes little
miniature like on sends
and like massage poles and like
little sets for his hamster,
like kind of play around and.
Yeah. There's like a little
mini waterboarding scene as well.
- Supporting your hamster.
- Yeah. But it's like, it's really cute.
And it's like, you know,
and then for some reason he was just like,
"Yeah, I'm just gonna make
them fight to the dead."
- He would make hamsters
drop right from like here
onto the floor.
It's not deadly, but it's
like, why would you make.
- It's not deadly, but I'm sure you know,
one bad fall and it could hurt.
- Hands on hearts.
- It's cool.
Like hamster, squid game.
- Yeah.
- Hamster. If you look up hamster.
- Squid game, squid game.
- God, I think it's a Hamster.
- I'm done with squid game.
It was is right TV show.
But let's never speak.
- Chris would've done it better,
Chris would've done it better.
- Octopus game, it's a squid game.
It's good. It's good.
Yeah. It's good.
- What would you change about it?.
- Don't wanna hear about it ever again.
It's been done a lot, right?
You know, we've.
- It has been done a lot.
- Squid game and yeah's, that's never.
- You think it about too popular.
- I think, I just you know,
I get a bit annoyed with things
that everyone obsesses over.
I remember.
Well, I remember when I was
here when frozen came out.
Right?
- Yeah.
- And you might been here,
but like, it was like,
everyone got so obsessed with.
- Every fucking store you go is let it go.
And I'm like, I think you
are the ones that let it go.
- Let it go.
That song was like every
day, like 400 times.
- Oh my God,
- I wanna kill someone.
And I felt like that about
squid game a little bit.
Oh it was a good show. It was good.
I enjoy it a lot.
But like when you just
hear about something,
you bombarded by something so much.
- Japan's so good at that though.
It's like when there's
like one like viral,
like song that's high in
the chart's like, you know,
any song, any, it could be anything
it's just like every second
store is blasting it.
- My favorite thing is when
Japanese stores play obscenely
inappropriate songs in English.
In like a children's day kirk,
they don't know what
any of the words mean.
It's play like rap. That's
like super like fucked.
- Yeah. I remember I went
to this toy story and Sheia
once they were playing rap,
like loud on the speakers, I was like, ah.
- They were playing wap
in one of the supermarkets
I go to as well.
- And it was like the
uncensored motion as well.
I was like, "Whoa." I'm like, it's like,
there's like all these toys
everywhere. And I'm just like.
- Kind hewing about it.
- Other, a family restaurant.
They're playing 50 cents in the club.
I was like eating like a
ham sandwich or something.
Eating the in the club's
like little bird like.
- Chris came in, put the song on Chris.
- You love the song.
- The song that defines me
in the club sounds right.
- Oh, sorry.
- Just that.
Eating like some sandwiches
listening to that.
- That's so good.
- A family restaurant.
- Oh my God.
- Chill in here.
Sorry. I was kidding.
- Why do it so loudly?
- I dunno.
- Put your clothes on in silence.
Trying figure he's pushing my.
(Indistinct)
- Put your drip on Chris.
Come on, put your drip on.
- You want.
- No, no, no.
- No.
- Put the drip on Chris.
- Put the drip on.
Put it on.
- Want to walk off set.
- No,
- I thought putting it on over there.
- It's a hoodie you can't
wear with a raw skin.
- Raw skin.
- Exposed skin.
- That's my next YouTube.
- Can't have those oily
body oils all over.
- Raw skin.
- Knock all your figure cheek,
figurines off the shelf.
- Yeah. Of those $1,000.
- $1,000. Which one
was the most expensive?
- Probably the AER one.
That was actually a $1,000.
- That's justified that once.
Not the other ONES.
- I guess we bought that one Chris.
- Joey.
- Actually Joey did buy it as well.
- Joe bought the kids.
- I bought the other Kira.
- What is that?
- Where is the other Kira?
- The other room.
- Oh. Okay.
- How do you put on a
hoodie like a boomer.
I dunno how you managed
to find a way to do.
- How the fuck do you
put it on them, like.
- It's a fucking hoodie.
You do never wear hoodies. Wait, actually.
- I've never seen Chris on a hoodie.
- Yeah, no I've seen you wear a hoodie.
- Swamp monster. Coming out. All right
- We ever worn a hoodie for Chris.
- Oh my God. Chris on a
hoodie just looks like that.
Like hello fellow kids.
We need to give you a skateboard now.
- Oh my God.
- One of the kids now.
- Should have worn the
cap that you wore in the,
the previous episode.
- Look good.
- Good. Good.
- How you feel?
- You got the drip now Chris, sheep in it.
- Fuck off. That's premium
material there Chris.
- How much is it?
- That's an embroidery right there.
- $88.
- It's a good material. Right?
Trash Chas.
- Cut that out.
That's right.
- It just looks so weird.
- Way to, for something, right?
Yeah.
- I mean it's a large size.
- This is a size TV.
- Yeah. It's a large size size.
- Let's not beat around the bush here.
- I wear large.
- A doodle D I think, you
know, I'm at least a medium.
- In what universe?
COPI if I'm it.
In what universe are you medium?
- I might be big mouth, but
I could still fit into a.
- Is that what the health test has?
- Some fucking COPI if I've heard it.
- So what are your goals for 2022?
What we gonna expect from trash to,
because here's special.
The pew pine, Mr. Beast on finally.
- The wall fucking opens up.
- Yeah.
- I love to have pus on and
people from outside Japan,
as much as we want you on
for like a fifth time cruise.
- Japan announced, dunno.
- When Japan finally opens
up I'm never coming on here.
I'll buy on the window.
- Guys. I'm sorry.
Feelings coming on this week.
I'll come back next week.
- I didn't even how to
get here. I got on a taxi.
I was late. I got on a taxi, yeah.
And I put the address in for
the studio and it just does not
compute on Google for every reason.
- Really?
- So I put in the dress
for somewhere nearby.
Like it was a Domino's pizza.
- I like Domino's pizza.
- Such a dickhead,
going from take station.
So a Dominos in like.
- Take me to the Domino.
- Texture was like car. I was like, yeah,
it's here the Dominos.
And he is like, oh, what car?
Pizza's car? Like, love bit of pizza.
- I love pizza.
- Pizzas be awkward.
- When you helping fill
my next special Chris.
- What's that?
- Whenever there is a special.
What I'm waiting on your special. What?
Well, it'll be out by the it's one.
You'd like cook some food or something.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Well that's been out..
- That's already out by the time.
- Oh yeah.
- It I've been out.
- What about the fighting one?
- Fighting scraped.
Kendall, Kendall scraped.
- Kendall. I love Kendall.
- I love Kendall. Yeah.
- Kendall.
- This is the man.
This is the man who has
traveled all of Japan.
- I love Kendall.
- Have traveled all of Japan.
- Kendall with the trumpets.
- The Trump bow.
Trombone or Ken day.
- For new crack of terror.
- The trombone of Kendall.
- I am affable.
- Oh my God.
- What about you Chris?
- You working on anything else big?
- No.
- I mean, where'd you go
out from go Ken Wabi right?
- There's nothing, is there?
Yeah. So my friend who,
who can get me like anyone
to interview, he's like,
who do you wanna interview?
- Anyone.
- I dunno guy, I don't go.
You can probably like get
me, anyone bring me anyone.
And I just don't have any idea.
I don't really like, I
don't, there's no one
I actually wanna interview, you know.
- Prince Andrew?
- He's out there. Interesting.
Kind of much worse than
the last interview.
(indistinct)
And welcome bet you were like,
I love that interview.
I dunno.
And the problem is, the
comment I get a lot,
is like production quality is so good.
Production quality, I don't
really production qualities,
I don't really care about that.
He's killer. It's important ever standard.
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
- But or not if it's a Jerry Vlock.
- I think you've just done it.
- It's a second channel, but.
- I think you've just
done it so much that you,
I think you just subconsciously
put it together really well.
- Yeah.
- I don't think you are
like this mastermind
that everyone thinks you
literally just turn up,
but you make the most of every situation.
I think you're pretty good
at filming on the spot.
- Maybe. Yeah, yeah.
- You just have an eye for it.
- And whereas I would
give after the two takes
and be like, fuck it.
Chris is like, we'll everyone fuck off
and make us do like four more takes.
'Cause Chris is not happy with it.
Like Stanley this whole director,
all freezing, dying, hungry.
And Chris's like, nah.
- I need this drone shot.
- The people go on.
- You'd be my film.
- That's the film.
- Something very bad.
It would be something really bad.
- Chris would be, I'm
predicting this, right?
Chris would be like,
I want to be my movie.
What would be? So be the
racist white man or something.
That's what he would do.
- No acting required.
- Guys should do his best
to make me just basically
be lean out the Capar
from Jen. That's like.
- You know, where's the script, it's like.
- So up and be yourself.
- I feel like Chris would
try and sabotage at me
to the best of his ability.
- I would do that. I would do that.
- He would be like, oh your
ch your character is gluctus.
You have to eat this entire Wang sober.
It's like, oh my gosh.
- I dunno. Yeah, honestly,
I dunno what to do this year though.
I would like to do outside
Japan a little bit.
- Yeah.
- Get out there.
- Well, I haven't left
a, in like two years.
- Just not film as well.
- I haven't left Japan
in two years plus now.
- Yeah.
- And Japan as a country,
you need to get out of
at least once a year.
'Cause it's like one big fucking library.
And you have to sort of be
very careful with your manners
and you've gotta be, you know,
switched on all times thinking
about how you're affecting
other people and yeah. It
wears you down and yeah,
you do need to get out once
a year and it's been pretty
tough not going back or doing anything.
I haven't left the shores
of Japan for two years now.
- When was the last time you
like filmed a video in like
outside of Japan? Like
in the UK or wherever.
- I think I've only done it like once.
- I wasn't asking the movie.
- Oh, and that, yeah.
That was it.
- Yeah.
- That was it.
- I see the movie.
You had one other movie, right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Or one other video other.
- Yeah, but I, yeah.
I just need to go out
for a bit. I was, yeah.
I was planning to go back for
Christmas like you guys were.
And yeah, yeah.
- That didn't go well.
- Yeah, it didn't go too well.
And yeah. So.
- Anyway, you wanna film
aside from cracker tour?
- I do wanna see that.
Can we climb cracker
tour, does that think?
- I thought I am.
- I think to a certain point, you can.
- Can we, why.
- I'll be doing the drain. Don't I?
- You can climb that.
- I'll be doing the drain.
- I'll do the drain.
I'll do the drain time.
- But I do wanna do take for
granted and I know place,
we can Bungee jump and
give my perfect jump.
Do you wanna.
- Thank God you are there.
Thank God.
- You want a Bungee jump?
- Thank God.
- I'm gonna film it.
- You gonna do with me Chris.
- I'm gonna hold the camera on.
- That sounds fun. I wanna do that.
- Fun to do Bungee jump.
- Yeah, that sounds fun.
- Fucking know.
- I would like to.
- I think I'd be scary
than doing a sky dive.
- I'd I would rather sky dive.
- I won't do sky dive.
- I wanna sky dive.
- Well wacky weekend. Don't we?
- Why are we not doing it? Why do you.
- Well, I'm not doing it.
- Yeah. Y'all do it.
- Oh right.
We'll film that or straps
would go place serious.
- Then we can do it with gone.
- Well, I'll take both of you.
- Yeah, fuck it.
- Yeah fuck it let's do it.
- If you want.
- I'm all right, man.
- You Joey doesn't even like.
- Would do Bungee jump?
- Oh yeah.
- Oh hell yeah then.
- I skydive as well. I want sky dive.
When's a trash skydiving.
- I wouldn't mind skydiving honestly,
but I think Bungee jumping,
I would not wanna do
there's something like,
like there's something
scary about an awkward hype.
You know what I mean?
Like, whereas like, 'cause like for me,
skydiving is like,
you are so high up where
height doesn't matter anymore.
- I've heard so many funny
stories about Bungee jumping
and like really sketchy countries.
- Yeah.
- It's like a do do something.
- People do die doing it.
- Yeah.
- I was in art school
last year girl did it
and the rope just wasn't tied.
- Exactly.
- I've imagined this.
- Let's be honest.
The one country you probably
wanna Bungee jump in with
confidence, it is probably Japan.
- Yeah.
- The man is like, "I
made this rope by hand.
It's all handcrafted or something."
- Passed down from
generation to generation.
- Yeah. It would be like the most
imaculate Bungee cord existence.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Like nest needs to
study it or something.
- Yeah.
- I bet. It's amazing.
- That's 'cause that's
everything is in Japan.
- Yeah.
- Nothing can be subpar.
Everything has to be like
the best thing on earth.
- Exactly.
- That's the video, Chris.
There you go.
- What's the health and
safety regulations in Japan?
- Imaculate.
- Because. Okay. Okay.
Here's.
- Over the top.
- Here's the thing it's like
it's either one or the other.
'Cause sometimes it's like
imaculate you are not going to go
to this place unless
everyone's signed off on it.
And then you have like
drifting where you can turn up
without fucking driver's
license and go on the course.
I'm just like, so where
does the line start?
- I feel like rules are made
when people do dumb shit
and accidents happen.
- Yeah.
- I feel like in some sense,
Japan doesn't have as many
rules because they're just
so conscious about.
- Yeah.
- Stuff like that.
- Mm.
- Yeah.
- Like I think like everyone
is just extremely clean here.
So I imagine their health rules probably
aren't as strict on like I imagine maybe.
- I think maybe.
- 'Cause they're so lean in general.
- Yeah. I think though, like in Japan,
because Japanese people just
like love to follow the rules
and are really good at
following the rules.
- Yeah.
- So it's like just have
like a baseline rule set
and then most places will be like,
oh you're not gonna do
anything like weird and stupid
to like, you know, try and
test those limits, all right?
'Cause everyone's gonna follow the rules.
- You're drifting is fun though.
- Yeah.
Whereas with drifting, no
like do you have a license?
No. All right you can still drive.
- Actually I didn't drift that day.
I know I'd have been sick like you were.
- I wanna see you drift.
- When I was in the back
of it. Just for that like.
- Few minutes. Yeah, yeah.
- It's way different when
you're driving it. I think.
- Yeah. When you're in the
back, you get way sick man.
- It was really fun.
I really wanna do it again.
- Yeah. I want to.
- That was fun. Yeah.
- One day I'll buy a new tyre.
- I like to see you
with like the drift king
drifting you around.
- Yeah.
- I would like to.
- Drifting.
- My life has hasn't flashed
before my eyes before,
but they definitely did
during that drifting.
- Yeah.
- That drifting episode.
- Mum was insane.
- Yeah.
- I don't even know.
Wanna know how to learn,
how to do that shit.
- IRP.
- This episode is sponsored by Manscaped.
- Cheers to 2022 and resolutions.
You can actually keep.
How about having clean and
shiny balls all year round.
Our sponsor at Manscaped are
here to save your balls this
year and make the ball drop into 2022
the cleanest and sexiest ever.
Set your first new year's
resolution with good intentions
and join the 4 million men
worldwide who trust Manscaped.
With our exclusive offer
go to Manscaped.com
and use code TrashTaste for Trump sent off
plus free shipping.
- It's new year, new me
with the global leaders
in below waste grooming.
This year take your
package to the next level
with the performance package 4.0
and brand new ultra premium body wash.
- Inside the performance
package 4.0 you'll find
the signature lawn mower 4.0.
This electric trimmer
is designed to trim hair
on loose skin.
The advanced skin safe
technology reduces cuts
and knicks on your delicate nuts.
It also comes equipped with
a 4,000 K LED spotlight that
will shine a light to the
promise land 2022 looks to be.
- So what are you waiting for?
Get 20% off and free
shipping by using code
TrashTaste @mansskip.com.
That's 20% off plus free
shipping @Manscaped.com
using code TrashTaste.
It's a new year, no pubes
in 2022 with Manscaped.
- Thank you for sponsoring D's nuts.
- Fuck sake Joey.
- Fuck to the new episode.
- Speaking of Rank cyber Chris,
I know another YouTube creator
you are very fond of,
Nikocado Avocado. Right?
- Nik Avocado.
- Nikocado Avocado.
- I see the guy that eats everything.
- Yeah and cries. Yeah.
- The bang thing.
- What's the story behind him?
I mean, I'm not as good as you are.
Like you are like switched on.
- I don't really know.
- Yeah. It's YouTube .
- In the YouTuber, law.
- Yes.
Him with the crew in it.
And I'm like fuck off.
- I watched the four hour video about him,
that explained all his history
and I can't tell you anything about it.
- Oh, the right opinion video.
- Yeah.
- And he was basically a
guy just was getting views
doing mark bang fat and then kind of just.
- But he used to be like
a health con like vegan.
- Yeah.
- He used to be super thin.
- Super thin, super healthy.
Used to promote like healthy eating.
- Oh, that's quite interesting character.
- Yeah.
- What the fuck.
- And then he did one mock
bang saw how big it got
and then just spiral.
- Oh sad.
- Yeah.
- That's really sad.
- And it's, I think it's
gotten to the point now
where he is definitely
playing a character.
- Yeah, he's playing it up.
- Yeah.
- He's completely like.
- But he's also very.
- But he's also eating the food.
- But he's also killing himself.
- It's method acting.
- Yeah.
- To.
- Method acting.
- To the end degree.
- I feel about eating fried chicken.
- I remember when Daniel
Day Lewis was eating
all the fried chicken and the character.
- Oh man. That's sad though. Isn't it?
- Yeah. But Mark Banks in general
are like the saddest earth.
- Maybe I'll do it.
- What you gonna do?
We basically did that.
- That's a (Indistinct).
- That's you did already, right?
Ramen as well.
- This is something.
- Avocado, man.
- But I feel like a one
off you're like, right.
- What's his name?
- Nikocado Avocado.
- Nick avocado.?
Yeah.
Nikocado.
- Nick Avocado..
- Yeah. Why is he called that?
- I don't know.
- Ask him.
- Where's do I ask him?
- I feel like mug band.
- Bring him here. Bring him on in.
- Probably watch this clip.
He watches all the clips about him.
- Yeah.
- And reacts to them.
- He's probably gonna react to this.
- Put your health first mate.
Don't get cholesterol
like him, sort it out.
- I think I might, I don't
wanna, you know, assume,
but I think he might have
higher cholesterol than me.
- Oh really?
- What?
But, so he was health conscious
when he just got rid of it.
He just was like, no.
- 'Cause he didn't get views.
- He didn't get views. Yeah.
- So money was more important.
- Money and drama got.
- Yeah. He basically chased
the money and dRamena,
like train and.
- Yeah.
- So yeah, him eating
unhealthy and dRamena got him
more views, which in
turn got in more money.
So it was like a.
- Endless spiral.
- Was a spiral.
- Yeah. I mean.
- This is the feature of
YouTube though, isn't it?
- No.
- Just punishing yourself.
for views.
- I mean, I've done that plenty of times.
I think like a Mark Bang
every now and then is like,
all right, whatever.
You're not putting your health at risk,
but when you're like, here's
my daily mark bang of.
- Yeah.
- Fifteen hundred chicken nuggets.
It's just like, maybe
this is a slight period.
- If you're doing like a
Matt Stoney where it's like,
you know, eat a Gargan
amount of food once a month,
but also work out vigorously
in meal, that's fine.
- So he does what he
does right, that study.
- Well, but I think he,
I think a lot of the professional leaders,
they eat that at large amount of food.
And then the days off,
they pretty much don't eat much they eat
very, very like precise diet.
- So there's a science.
There's an.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's like if you eat 7,000 calories,
you've gotta figure out
how you can get that
out of your diet.
- Yeah.
- Or you can have the lack of calories.
- I think he messaged me once.
'Cause he did the Monster
Ramen challenge in bar.
That we did.
- Oh, okay.
- He completely nailed.
In a way that I could only dream of.
- Yeah.
- But I didn't realize that he's actually
quite good about it.
- He's like one of the
like best in the world.
- If an avocado man, just everyday.
- Yeah.
- Fuck off that shit.
- Stop calling him avocado, man.
- I remember I just
picked like an avocado.
- What?
- Nick Avocado.
- I think that's,
I don't even think he can
eat as much as Maston.
Like Mastons is like insane.
- Yeah.
- That's sounds like
it's just like inhuman.
- But like he's also like
trained professionally,
I guess, to the point of where
he knows what he's doing.
- Is he trained professionally?
- Well, I mean, well.
- I mean he competes like professionally.
- He's the king at it.
Like no one beats him.
- Yeah.
- I think there's like a few other people
who are pro, as good as him.
I mean, he's got a lot of the records.
- I think most of the stuff.
- He probably knows what he's doing.
- I think the reason why he
doesn't upload as frequently
is not just for health reasons.
But I think it's also
because he's like doing like
professional eating competitions, like.
- Wow. Wow.
- I mean, I'm guessing
it's still not healthy
what he's doing.
- No, I used to me a
video of him just eating
like a hundred slice of cheese.
- Oh, that was so gross.
- That looks this.
I wanted to throw up
just watching that video.
- Once he is had his first endoscopy,
he'll think very carefully about
feed fighting strap strategy.
- I'm sure that man has
like the best healthcare
that money can buy.
- I think he'll just eat
the camera. Won't he?
- It goes well, what happened to that guy
who did a man versus food?
- Oh, Adam something.
- I was gonna say Adam Levine.
And I was like, no, that's.
- That's more fine.
- I always thought that
if Chris was American,
that's how he lit like.
- Man, versus food.
- Just me with better teeth
and the better jawline
and just everything better.
- Where's the family
Mar chicken challenge.
- A hundred pieces of family Mar chicken.
- Oh, imagine Levine
after family Mar chicken.
- Animal Levy's not his name.
- After a bucket of chicken.
- I mean, it's just depressing. Isn't it?
I feel like there's only
so much you can do before.
You're just like, "I
don't like this anymore.
I'm just hurting myself.
I'm just in pain."
- Did you not feel like that after
you did your cup noodle challenge?
- Yeah. I felt awful.
That's why I only do it
like once every month.
- That's after I one cup noodle,
I feel like you insulting.
- I'm not eating it all am
I? I'm taking one bite of it.
- Yeah. But collectively you probably ate
about five or six cups.
- Yeah.
- Six old cup.
- A brave man.
You're an idiot.
- Full of sodium.
- Yeah. Too much sodium,
so too much sodium.
Why? Again, it's one of those things like
you're not doing it often.
So whatever really mean
cholesterol still high,
but you know.
- Are you gonna do more?
I tried X, Y, Z videos
or I tried everything.
- It's just not that much
to do. It's interesting.
- You kinda covered did.
- It was pretty rubbish. It
was just like, that's pretty,
they all looked the same, but.
- Then it was also,
'cause I just moved in and
like everything was a mess
and we couldn't get any of
the camera set up or line.
- Yeah. You filming me con's apartment.
And like he had had no curtains.
- Yeah. We had the curtains had the.
- To block out the sun. He used a
like 20 boxes and a blap doll.
Something like his collection
of dodgy videotapes to.
- He loved mother's nose, breast.
- Mother, nose, breast. The
masterpiece of our time.
- You couldn't stop
giggling when he saw it,
he was like, what? Why
is mother nose breast.
- He did actually watch.
She should have.
- Why is mother nose, breast John.
- It's his favorite shot.
- It's wonderful.
- He used these tapes to
block out like the sun.
- Yeah. It somewhat works.
- Porn eclipse, like block out the sun.
But I was also.
- Solar eclipse of porn.
It was, yeah, it did not work well.
And the Chris, they all were just so shit.
There's nothing interesting about.
- If you had been to the UK,
it would've been really good.
Not too much west chips.
- Not like the US chips.
- It just really showed how
depressing crisps are Japan.
- Yeah. What did somebody
messaged me in the week and said,
Chris, your friends with
the Trash Taste lad.
I was like, oh yeah.
And of course I am. And they're like you,
next time we see him tell to
stop going so hard on America.
What have you done? I think
it was you as well is like,
particularly in calor what
have you said about America?
That's made everyone angry.
- We said a lot of stuff about America.
- We said a lot more than
they've said about the UK
quite frankly.
- What's your opinion of America Chris?
- So right now. I mean, I don't,
it's silly to make
sweeping generalizations
about the entire country.
- Yeah.
- But if we were to do that.
- It's not like I'm actually like
generalizing the entire population.
It's just for joke.
- Well, I think in the UK,
we are like a little bit
snobby towards Americans.
- Of course we are, of course.
- We're like in a car, every
garage, chicken, every pots.
- Towards everyone. Let's be honest.
- We invented the rocket engine.
We got televisions and that.
- It's like.
- We are a little bit envious.
Cause we had pie and then
it was gum and then America
had a bigger and better
economy and everything.
- Oh you could be worse.
- Do you do you know what I
think, do you know what I think
like British people hate about Americans
is that they look happy.
You know.
- That's true.
That's true.
- You know,
I think Americans hate
what they can't have.
- That's exactly it.
That's exactly it.
- Happiness.
- You look at American
culture and everyone's freedom
and everyone's so optimistic
and happy and like patriotic
and we are here just
being like country in it.
Why they so happy?
No, no. Aren't we happy?
- That makes sense.
What we should learn from Americans
is good to like how have
dreams and be optimistic.
We don't have that in the UK.
I remember like, you know,
I used to work in office
and I'd be like, I wanna start a business.
They were like, fuck off and
get me my tea, little prick.
And I was okay. And like just
having a dream in the UK,
you just can't do that. You know what?
Shut up and make the tea.
- It's like, that is the.
- Sit down Chris. Get me my
fucking tea, like is horrible.
The UK's horrible.
- Could that possibly be
a generalization as well?
- I do miss a part.
- Imaginably Chris being scolded
is the funniest thing in.
- British people, miserable in it.
- We are miserable.
- I remember when Elon
Musk came to the castle
where I worked, right?
My boss was really up
type bitch of a woman.
And she's like, really, really
like, she's like really posh.
Like when you work at a prestigious place,
you get like really posh people.
And I look, she was like,
"There's billionaire coming
here called Elon Musk
or something started a company worth
300 million bonds rubbish."
And I was like, "Yeah,
he's made a company
called Tesla and Space X."
RA was, it might wanna talk to him.
I was like, "He's pretty big deal."
Like she was like, really
looked down at him,
just being why I just being American.
There's nothing else.
- Not an American.
- American.
- This woman I could,
this person I work with.
just hated him.
'Cause he was like American.
And he came with like lots
of Silicon investors and.
- All right.
- Half of people.
- I had a new picture idea to them.
- I've got an idea for business.
- That must be like the fringiest thing
you could possibly do.
- Yeah. And then they all just ha ha.
- I just didn't wanna talk to him.
And they like, let me deal with him.
And I'd like, give him the birthday cake
'cause she didn't want it.
She's like 50.
- Weird.
- Why?
- I dunno.
- Maybe she had a Tesla
car it with or something.
- Odd, didn't it.
- I don't wanna hear about him.
- It was very odd, very odd.
But you know, we're talking
to gum before we came on
about how like if you go to
a nice restaurant in Japan,
you just, you don't
feel judged. It's nice.
- No.
- You go to a nice restaurant
in the UK, like Michelin star.
- Yeah.
- You will feel like nothing.
You'll feel like.
- You sure you'll feel outta place there.
- The class structure in the
UK is pretty powerful still.
And you know, if you go
in a nice restaurant,
you often they'll be like,
"Oh, what are you doing here?"
Especially when you turn up dress like me.
They're like, "Oh gosh,
what are you doing here?"
- Yeah.
- The toilets are not here.
So it's just.
- They don't really care
where you're from in Japan.
But I feel like it does
for a bit in the UK.
They're like, "Where did you grow up?"
And it's like.
- It's just fascinating coming
from a country that doesn't
have that, that like
what, like how does, like,
where does it stop?
How do you distinguish between
who is in the same class as you?
- And dress.
- 1000 years of history and money. It was.
- 'Cause there's like
so much old money there.
Right?
- Yeah.
- It gets inherited down
and they get brought up.
Like own circle or own environment.
- It just sounds like
racism within the same race.
- I mean it's called classism, right?
- Yeah.
- There's literal name for it.
Right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You said somebody made fun of you
for your clothes you wear or something.
- So, yeah. I went to this
fancy restaurant in the UK
and someone laughed at us for wearing,
you know, wearing like
Unichlo and H and M clothes.
- Disgusting.
- What? Disgusting.
- Who laughed at you?
- Huh?
- Which, what person was this?
- Or like a waiter or.
- No, no, just someone sitting at a table.
We got looks for, you know,
having like smart
business, casual clothes.
- Yeah.
- But obviously none of
it was like main brand.
- Actually I turn up in
my prime mark jacket.
- I was always of the mindset
of like the real rich people.
Like actual, rich didn't
feel the need to dress smart.
They just turned up and
like pajamas to restaurants.
- That's like American rich, right?
Where people have new money.
In the UK there's old money.
Right?
- Yeah.
- Passed down.
- It's like name value to the money.
- I feel really out my depth of the London
when I gotta go back.
- Me too.
- At this place like.
- That's why I just buy
anything on one of the menu at
McDonald's that's the real wealth.
- That's the flex.
- That's the real power.
- Do you guys want some nuggets?
I suppose I would buy another 20.
- Get 20 piece cent.
- I'm gonna ask an extra sauce.
- It's Bougie.
But the 20 nuggets.
- But the restaurants are shit in London.
It's like London five,
our hotels for a joke.
Like it's like, it looks
like my grandma's bedroom.
It's like, it's old and quaint.
It's been around for hundreds
of years. And it's like, yeah.
That's why my grandma still
has the bed. It's shit.
It's like this fucking awful.
Like, you know, you see these rooms,
they have like a 12 inch
screen from like the 1980s.
They have these bed sheets that look like,
they're just therapied.
- Yeah.
- This Oak cabinet that looks
like it's been around longer
than like the entirety of
London. It's like piece of shit.
And you pay like 400 pounds a night.
- Yeah.
- You get nothing.
- I mean, I feel Japan
kind of has that as well
with some of their Johans as well.
- I thought that until I stayed
in some of the London hotels,
and then I'd forgotten
how, how overpriced London,
the service industry is in the UK.
'Cause for what you get in
like the price you pay for,
like, you can stay in
some like five star hotels
or whatever, and you are paying like four,
five times the price you would in Japan.
And it would be like half the size
of the room with no service.
It doesn't even come with toothbrushes.
Like it doesn't even
come with toothbrushes,
which I think is like the bare minimum.
- I remember that.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause in Japan, any, even
the worst hotel in the world,
I went to.
- Take it to environmental reasons, right?
- We we got toothbrush, right?
- I wouldn't use it.
- It was Canton like
molds and every disease.
- But it was there.
- And cut.
- But mold in blood in this room.
But at least it came with a toothbrush.
- Exactly. Right?
- I think the UK doesn't do it
for like environmental waste.
- Yeah.
Yeah. Environmental waste.
- Which also just suddenly
lines up very nicely for these
hotels because they don't
have to buy toothbrushes.
- Very true.
- Yeah.
- Where are the five stars
coming from in that case?
Just from the main value.
- I can't understand how they
get five stars sometimes.
'Cause I think it must be
location half the time.
So like a lot of these five star hotels
are in amazing locations.
- Yeah.
- But the hotels are dreadful, really bad.
Don't go in a five star hotel in London.
Just go to like a premier in or some shit.
- Yeah. Airbnb maybe.
- Airbnb is like way better.
You get way you better
in London than yeah.
In England in general.
Like pretty much every hotel
I've stayed in in England
is like, not the greatest.
- Did I tell you the time
I got locked inside Airbnb
in England. I used to use Airbnb a lot.
And then I stayed in
Bath once for a holiday,
really nice town city called Bath.
And it was in like an attic.
It's like Quasimodo up there.
But like, I, yeah, the door wouldn't open.
The door wouldn't open from the inside.
So I woke up that morning.
I was like, I'm gonna go
for a jog around Bath.
And you went to the door. It
just, it just wouldn't open.
I was like, what the fuck?
And I, there was no way I could open it.
I rang up the guy. I was
like, "Hey man, I can't get up
the apartment, this kind of weird."
This isn't ever happened
in the history of ever.
And it was, "Oh, it happens sometimes.
You sure it won't open?" I
was like, no, I was like,
can you come and sort
out? It was like, well,
I'm in Bristol at the moment,
which is about an hour now.
I was like, if there's a fire, I'm fucked.
And like, and I had to wait
like an hour for someone to come
and like open the door and
let me out of the apartment.
Someone knocked inside.
And that put me off there
the Airbnb in the UK.
- Yeah. The one.
- Did you leave a bad review?
- I think I did.
I was like, got locked in the room.
- That was bad as it get.
- That is pretty bad.
- That's the only thing that
I sometimes don't like about
Airbnb is that there's
some weird unpredictable,
just nature's to the.
- Well, I did it in Osakso
once and the owner was like,
"Just say, you're our friends.
Just say, you know, just say
your friends with Takashi."
I was like, "Yeah, all right."
- It's weird. Isn't it?
- If someone that bumps
into you in the corner,
like yeah. Tekes someone chy this you.
- So, you know, if you're
logging around like
expensive equipment, I
wouldn't go to Airbnb.
- Right. Yeah, yeah.
- I just don't trust it.
Like if I have my top camera,
stuff like that. Yeah.
You've known insurance.
You've no safety, you know?
And if it's, if someone
else also has the keys,
it's a bit worrying.
- Yeah.
- Obviously the hotel has,
you know, people keys as well,
but you can at least there's
some level of safety there
and there's cameras everywhere.
- Yeah. Hotels have cameras.
- So it's, you know, it depends.
If I was just traveling
with me somewhere on my own,
didn't ring my laptop, an angle.
I would staying there at Airbnb.
- And I tried to last week
when we were trying to make a video.
We went to this real expensive hotel room,
a $12,000 hotel room.
And I wanted to contrast
that with something bad,
like a bad hotel room or cheap Airbnb.
I'm trying to book three,
separate Airbnb in Tokyo.
And they're all like, oh,
it's open these few days.
I booked it. And three times
in a row I got rejected.
They were like, "No, we're full that day."
And I got really angry
at this point about that.
I dunno if it's 'cause,
you know, I'm not Japanese.
A lot of people said afterwards
that they always book under
a Japanese name and.
And I was quite disappointed about that.
I was like, "Oh, maybe it's
'cause of the new Omni variant."
And so they're being a bit
wary 'cause I'm foreign, but.
- Stopped fuck up though.
That's pretty susceptible
- Classic Japanese xenophobia over there.
- Well. There's been some
nasty instances of that
since COVID, you know,
it certainly times I've felt
like a second class citizen
in Japan 'cause you during COVID right.
- You know, before I would
never have accused Japan of
you know that level of discrimination,
but yeah COVID has really kind
of brought out a weird side
of Japan. There's a bit uncomfortable.
- It's a lot of people are
spoken to sort of tainted their
long term future here.
- Yeah. Really, really
good article about how like
all these travel
restrictions have really like
tainted how a lot of people view Japan.
- Unfortunately.
- How they've just kind of
just completely fucked over
foreigners who had jobs, residencies here.
- Yeah.
- Like really students
absolutely fucked over
a ton of people and now they
just put them back and said,
they're gonna keep them
going again right after
they released them. It's really fucked..
- It is bad. Yeah.
- Well. I remember like
you got so bad that
the American embassy even made a tweet.
- Right?
- Didn't it?
Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Jesus.
- Well, the tweet was sent,
like we've been informed that
Japanese police are
randomly stopping foreigners
and searching them.
- Oh yeah. I had that the other day.
- Yeah Joey had it.
- Oh yeah. You had that.
- The day after that.
- You were searched.
- The day after the tweet,
the day after the tweet,
I was at the nearby like train station
and I was about to go into the train thing
and then a cop just like stopped me.
He was like, "Oh (foreign language)"
and it was like only, and I'm like, yeah,
I'm dejavu.
And he was like, oh we
doing fucking dijervu.
(indistinct chatters)
- No. Nice.
- And then he was like, no,
like I'll give this cop credit.
He was nice about the whole thing.
But he was like, yeah, so
we've heard about this case
that's been and going around
where people are picking up
credit cards of people and
using them without their
permission.
So I need you to like open your wallet
and I need to see some identification
and I need to see the
names on your credit cards.
- I doubt that.
- And at first I was like,
"What the fuck is this like scam shit."
- That sounds like the
most bullshit story.
- And so I.
- You said the wallet inspector at the.
- Yeah, no. So for the
first time ever, I was like,
"Can I see your identification please?"
Cause I wasn't too sure.
Right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I was like, I need to
make sure this guy's a cop.
So I was like, can I
see your identification?
And he looked at me
like, "What do you mean?
I'm obviously dressed up as a cop"
and I'm like, "No, no, no.
I need to see like your badge."
He showed me his badge.
I was like, okay, looks fine.
Gave HIM the wallet.
He saw my Japanese name on my credit card.
- Yeah.
- And he was like,
"Oh, (speaking in Japanese)."
And I was like, yes.
Immediately gives me back my wallet.
And he was like, oh, those
over this have a good day.
- Sorry. I thought you were fine.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So basically, yeah, he saw
my Japanese name was like,
"Fuck you're Japanese. Whoops my bad.
Here's your wallet back, have a good day."
And just went off.
And then I stopped and just
kind of hit away to just see
if he would stop anyone
else, for like five minutes
he didn't stop anyone else.
He was just walking around.
Probably waiting for the next foreigner.
So I was like, God, what if
it'd been con it'd been shot?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause just tased on the spot.
- My credit written off.
You know, it's also really annoying about,
I guess just cops and security
people in Japan is that you
cannot tell the difference by
looking from a security guard,
a cop in Japan, they all dress the same.
All the building,
like managers stuff also
dressed like military forces.
Why?
- Really. Because like
every mall I've been to
the security guard is
like an 80 year old dude.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Dude.
- And I'm like, what are you guarding?
- You going to some buildings
and the security are dressed
like they're gonna war.
And it's like.
- Where are you going?
- I dunno, just everywhere I go.
They're all dressed in like
these military outfits.
It's so weird.
- Maybe I like the embassies and show.
- No. I've never been to embassy in Japan.
- All the security guard
I've seen are like,
"Yeah. All decrepit."
- Yeah. They're like 60, 70 year old dudes
with like the blue hats. And they're like.
- Where the hell do you go?
- Yeah.
- The person getting dodgy massaging.
- It's like two places.
Japanese businessmen
retired like, taxi driver
and taxi drivers. Right?
That's what I thought.
- Yeah, something hat can put
people's to lives in danger.
- I look at these like 70 year old,
like security guards and I'm like, okay,
let's say hypothetically.
I like, you know, well,
no steal some shit, what are you gonna do?
- What the security guards
in Japan do they are there
to call the police.
- Yeah. Basically.
- Probably they do.
- Yeah.
- They're actually gonna hate you.
I've never seen a security guard.
- Just act like a civilian. Right?
- I mean, you know, or
you got, they call up
the group of 15 cops coming around you.
- No, but it was shocking
'cause I'd never been
stopped by like a cop before.
- No, I've never been stopped like that.
- That was the first time ever.
- You've never been stopped?
- I've never been stopped for 10.
- That was the first time ever.
- I've been stopped twice.
- Have you?
- What the fuck am serious?
- I dunno.
You did look a bit sort of dodgy though.
- Yeah.
- What, how the fuck do I look dodgy.
- I look at you and I think
that man needs to be arrested.
And he's done some shit.
Throw the key away.
Get outta it.
When did you presumably or something?
- One at a.
- One at the old studio, right?
- One at the old studio.
- Yeah.
- Police came in.
- Stop this recording.
- Is there a Mr. Goon in here.
- The old studio and one
at like around like Amachi
at that area.
- What did you, what have you done?
What'd you do?
- Nothing.
What did I do? Like I pissed on the floor.
- Now.
- No, I was walking and I was, again,
I was the only.
- You were alone.
- Yeah, I was.
I saw a bunch of dudes walk past
and this dude just
perked up when he saw me,
and just like came over
to me and just stopped me
and that's for my like ID and all that.
And I was like.
- what did he do?
- Nothing I gave you. I
was like, what do you want?
I can clearly see that
he was a police officer.
And I was like, all right, well,
I guess I'll show it to you.
And I was just bantering and
staffing him told me about
his favorite games and it was weird.
I was telling him that my train
was leaving in two minutes
and he, he came, he hired up.
- It's interesting 'cause that experience
sounds really wrong. Right?
The whole sort of, he just
stops you grab nothing.
'Cause you'll just look like that
and, but then he was nice.
So it was kinda like really
trying to reconcile the nicest.
- He was nice. You know, if
I don't understand why he,
I wish that there was an explanation,
even if he tried to explain to me,
I wouldn't have understood anyway,
but it didn't really seem like
he tried to explain why he
was stopping me. He just stopped
me and was like ID please.
- Well, I mean he gave me an explanation
and just sounded like a scam.
- Oh. The dude straight
up was like ID, ID card.
He just wanted my residence
card. And I was like one,
you assume my resident card,
which I do, but maybe I didn't.
- Maybe. And that's the important point.
You always need to carry a residence card
if you live in Japan. If
you get caught without it,
you can get fined like
a hundred thousand Yen.
- Yeah. Like when we have,
can send our residence card off
to get renewed for our visa,
which you know, before happened
to be like every six months,
because we couldn't get
a visa beyond six months,
that like few weeks in
between us waiting to get.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah.
- Residence card.
That was just like.
- Use your passport or something.
- No. 'Cause we had to send
off our passport as well.
- Oh Jesus.
- So the only thing we had was.
- A little bit of paper saying.
- Yeah. Yeah.
This is this document that says that,
there's not even like a document.
It's an email that says, "Oh,
they've sent it off and
they're getting it renewed."
And I dunno how friendly the cops would be
if I just open up this email.
- They're pretty, they'd
be pretty understanding.
I think they're just, yeah.
I don't know. I think.
- It's just that first
hurdle they have to get over.
I don't have an ID card.
So every time I'm like,
I don't have a ZY card.
I'm like ready to like write the ticket.
Like you don't have a ZD card.
No, I have to explain.
Yeah.
- $10,000 go.
- Yeah.
- I don't really get
too offended about it.
It's a bit annoying, but
I wish they would just tell
me why they're doing it.
- Random stop and search, you know?
- Yeah. Random. Random. Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
Random.
- Yeah. Because like I've
never seen a cop do that
with a Japanese person. Like I don't.
- The only time I've ever
seen cop talking to Japanese.
- Until me, but I don't look Japanese. So.
- Literally I've ever seen
cops talking to Japanese
people are like,
when someone's shouting or
there's been a car accident,
that's only time I've ever seen it.
- Yeah. Like when there's an actual.
- I dunno if I'm just being biased,
I could totally be being
like anecdotal evidence here
being completely biased.
- I mean, that's usually what it is.
Like when there's an actual problem,
then the cops get involved.
But when it's just a white
guy walking down the streets
apparently it's like, oh I do part time.
- It's never happened to me.
And the police I've met have been always
very nice and friendly.
- Yeah. Yeah. Like I said, like.
- They're all nice. They're all nice.
Yeah. Which is a good thing.
- I told the guy I wanted to
get my train in two minutes
and he kind of hurried up.
- Yeah.
- That's good.
I was like, need to get that one.
And he was like, oh, see my sense.
And.
- I got stopped for speeding once.
I was getting like four
kilometers brow over the limit.
And it was one of the ways
situations where I just saw.
- I was going four kilometers
per hour, that's speeding.
- And they were stopping everyone.
They were just stopping all the cars.
'Cause everyone just in the countryside
goes over the limit a little bit.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Okay the speed limit is so low.
- It's very low here.
They apologize to pulling
me over that, "Oh my God.
We're so sorry. We're so sorry.
We know this is ridiculous."
- We're so sorry to inform you
that you're breaking the law.
- They kind of knew that it
was a bit petty and I sort of,
they could be doing something.
- They give you points.
- Yeah. I got a few points I think.
- For that.
- For four kilometers.
- Pay like some money.
- Oh my gosh.
- Jesus.
- How mean?
- Might've been seven kilometers.
- Why are they pulling you over.
- A hundred and fifteen.
I mean a lot of people do go like 110
on the like 70 or 80 miles.
- Yeah. 'Cause the highways like 80.
- Yeah. So the mass power is like, what?
50 maximum?
- Yeah.
- 50 mass per hour on the highways.
You're not getting
anywhere 50 miles an hour.
- That's true yeah.
- But I get, it's a small
country, but you know,
people gotta go.
- Well, you know.
- What about the UK.
It's not a small country.
Right?
- That's why like, you know,
you're not surprised
when you're seeing like,
would just be like cars, tons of them.
Just get like 110.
- Yeah, yeah.
- For all of them do it. None
of them follow the rules.
But apparently I was told,
I dunno if this is true,
it's the person in front
who gets the blame.
If everyone's like speeding behind.
- The leader.
- Yeah.
Whoever. 'Cause the
leader is clearly the one.
- The inside guy.
- Influence them.
I dunno how true that is.
I imagine if like 20 people are speeding,
they can't stop every car.
- Yeah.
Gotta set an example. Right?
- Piece of.
That's what I mean. If you,
I've noticed that whenever
like one car goes in
in the front, all the
other cars just go back in.
They don't wanna be the one in the front.
- Yeah.
That could be true.
- It makes sense.
- Yeah.
- Dunno if it could be
complete hysterical.
- It makes sense. But.
- I know.
- I realize I've been
looking at the wrong camera
the entire time, looking at
this one instead of that one.
- My God.
- You've been on this show
four times now, Chris.
- Oh my God.
- That could end the day,
Chris looking the wrong camera.
- Chris looking at the wrong
camera the whole episode.
Thank you, Chris.
- Thank you, Chris.
Mood on just punch in 400% digital.
- That be fun, Chris?
- Yeah. Always a blast.
- Only your fourth time here
you can't look at the right camera.
Maybe fifth time. Yeah. Maybe fifth time.
- Yeah. Fifth time is the time.
- Time's the direct cinematography.
- But at least I am affable.
And that is the main
takeaway from this episode.
Thank you for having me on board.
- You know, who else is affable?
Our patrons.
- On screen right now?
- We're on the screen right now.
- Of course.
- Absolutely.
- Oh, I love that name. Yeah.
- That one's really good well actually.
Well, me focus on Christmas.
- Yeah. Love David.
- Hey moon. That has
to put David there now.
- Thank you for having me
on. I hope to see you again.
Please let me back. You.
- You will be back.
- Comet, go Bungee jumping
Chris, Bungee jumping.
That's gonna be a lot of fun.
- Into a river? Let's get done.
Well, take it for granted.
- I'll go take it for granted.
- If we don't.
- It's in good me river.
- If we die, we at
least get it in eight K.
- You'll be CGI in future episodes.
Your states, they will have C do con CGI.
- Conna AI.
- I don't permit this at all.
- I permit.
- But Hey, if you'd like to be
affable and support the show,
then make sure to go up to our Patreon on
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow on Twitter,
send this to was on the sore.
And he paid our face,
listens to us on Spotify.
- Subscribe to Bungee band..
- Subscribe Bungee band.
- You know this guy already.
- Yeah.
- Can you share your socials, Chris?
- Yep.
Chris Abroad channel. It's the new
- Oh yeah. The Second channel.
- That's the new up
and coming place to be.
- Subscribe to his second channel.
- That's the main channel now.
- It's amazing.
- Bang episode. Thanks
yourself for joining us.
- Bye.
(soft music)